THESE INDICATIONS WILL NOT COME
TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYBODY AS WE CONTINUE TO TAKE
SOME PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE THE
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN RISKS.
THE SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME
THE PUBLIC AND HAS PROVIDED
ACCESS TO BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCE BUT DISPOSITION
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE THIS THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED OUR
COMMITTEE WHICH WEBSITE. DID
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
ONE EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE
ONE. FORTY ONE EIGHTY FIVE ONCE
AGAIN 840-429-1401 EIGHTY FIVE
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE SEVEN
ONE. FIFTY FIVE TWENTY TWO ONE
SEVEN ONE FIFTY FIVE TWENTY TWO.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HIT THE DURING THE HEARING.
AS A CUSTOMER AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTED MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED
WE ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL I
ASK ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
TO PRESENT THE STATE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBER SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH A OR QUORUM AND BEGAN
OUR HEARING- CLARK. CAN WE CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE. WESSEL HERE
WESSEL HERE DOLLY. BAKER.
GORGEOUS FOR JUST PRESENTS
BRADFORD. BRADFORD FEAR DOT.
EGGMAN EGGMAN HERE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ HERE. GROWTH HERTZBERG
. HERTZBERG HERE. MCGUIRE. MAN
MAN HERE RUBIO. RUBIO PRESENT
STERN. JERRY HAVE A QUORUM WE
HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE TEN BILLS
ON TODAY'S AGENDA AND WE DO HAVE
ONE CHANGE ON THE AGENDA WHICH
IS UP ITEMS NUMBER NINE AND TEN
ARE NOW BEEN MOVED TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR MINUTES ITEM
NINE S. B. TWELVE THIRTEEN AN
ITEM TO AN S. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE. MOVED TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR- NOW WE CAN MOVE UP TO
HEAR THE BILL FOR MY FIRST
AUTHOR WHICH IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE SENATOR ALAN S. B. TWELVE
FIFTY EIGHT A BILL RELATING TO
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION. ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING AND FLEET
OPERATOR AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES.
SENATOR THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS ACT MEMBERS
CALIFORNIA'S ADOPTED AMBITIOUS
GOALS IN OUR CONTINUED EFFORTS
TO COMBAT THE THREATS POSED BY
CLIMATE CHANGE INCLUDING
REDUCING GHG EMISSIONS THROUGH
STATEWIDE ADOPTION OF ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE IN REQUIRING ALL
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES IN
CALIFORNIA TO BE ZERO EMISSION.
BY TWENTY THIRTY. NOW THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM WAS
CREATED BY OUR LEGISLATURE BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT TO
PROMOTE. DEVELOPMENT AND
ADOPTION OF NEW TECHNOLOGIES TO
ACCELERATE. THE SHIFT AWAY FROM
NON RENEWABLE ENERGY SOURCES IN
THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. THE
PROGRAM UTILIZES PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE INVESTMENTS TO PROVIDE
GRANT FUND SUPPORTING INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS TO THE CLIMATE CRISIS
. ZERO EMISSION AUTONOMOUS RIDE
SHARE SERVICES ARE AN EMERGING
INDUSTRY- THAT CAN HELP TO
ACHIEVE ALLEGED VEHICLE AND
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION TARGETS
BY EXPANDING PUBLIC ACCESS. ZERO
EMISSION TRANSPORTATION. THE
PROGRAMS LIKE THE CDP THIS CREAM
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM HAVE NOT
YET BEEN UPDATED TO ACCOMMODATE
THESE NEW AV TECHNOLOGIES IN
EVALUATING THEIR ADVOCACY AND
HELPING THE STATE MEET VEHICLE
ELECTRIFICATION TARGETS. AT THIS
BILL TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT WILL
UPDATE C. T. P. ELIGIBILITY
CRITERIA TO INCLUDE ZERO
EMISSION AV INFRASTRUCTURE AND
REFUELING PROJECTS TO ALLOW
THESE TECHNOLOGIES CONSIDERATION
FOR GRANT FUNDING. THIS
ELIGIBILITY EXPANSION WILL
INCREASE EQUITABLE PUBLIC ACCESS
TO CLEAN TRANSPORTATION AND
BROADEN THE STATE'S ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND TESTIFYING THIS MORNING WE
HAVE A SALE BUT EITHER FROM
CRUISE. THE RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL WHEN. THE FOR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU WILL
BEGIN WITH- CONSERVE OUR
ALTHOUGH HE'S GOT- THREE MINUTES
TO- MAKE HIS ARGUMENTS AND THEN
WE HAVE ALSO AN OPPOSITION
SPEAKER THAT'LL HAVE THREE
MINUTES BUT BROUGHT WILL GO TO
JOSE A LOT OF THOSE SPEAKERS OF
SUPPORT AFTER- IS FOR SALE BUT
ALTHOUGH PRESENT. YES WE BEGIN.
GREAT THANK YOU TERM MEMBERS MY
NAME'S ALVARADO AND I'M HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF AN ALL
ELECTRIC THE TIME IS THE OF A
COMPANY CALLED CREWS TO EXPRESS
OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR SENATE
BILL TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT. CRUZ IS
PROUD TO BE THE ONLY A TIME IF
YOU HAVE A COMPANY OPERATING AND
ALL ELECTRIC 1100% RENEWABLY
POWERFULLY. ON CALIFORNIA'S
ROADS. SINCE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
CRUZ SAYS SOURCE THAT'S A NEW
WINNER G. FROM FARMS IN
CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL VALLEY. FOR
A FLEET OF ALL ELECTRIC SELF
DRIVING VEHICLES. GENERATING NEW
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FARMERS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
WE ARE PASSIONATE ABOUT CREATING
A SAFER MORE SUSTAINABLE MORE
EQUITABLE TRANSPORTATION FUTURE
THAT CAN BENEFIT OUR
COMMUNITIES. CALIFORNIA SENATE
AMBITIOUS SUSTAINABILITY GOALS
AND IN ORDER TO MEET THOSE WE
MUST ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
NECESSARY TO MOVE TOWARDS A
CLEANER TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. SENATE
BILL TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT BOB
ADVANCE OUR CLIMATE GOALS BY
ALLOWING ZERO EMISSION
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE FLEETS SB
ELIGIBLE FOR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING.
EXPANDING ELIGIBILITY WILL
PROVIDE AN INNOVATIVE SOLUTION
TO INCREASING ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED.
ADDITIONALLY THEY'LL HELP TO
CREATE A MORE EQUITABLE
TRANSPORTATION FUTURE BY
ALLOWING ANYONE TO TAKE A GREEN
RIDE. REGARDLESS THAT THEY CAN
AFFORD ELECTRIC VEHICLE OR HAVE
ACCESS TO A CHARGER. CALIFORNIA
HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
TO SUPPORT THE BUILD OUT OF
THEIR MISSION INFRASTRUCTURE WE
NEED MORE. THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM HAS
PROVEN TO BE AN EXCELLENT WAY TO
ADVANCE GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE IN
CALIFORNIA GREAT NEW GREEN JOBS
AND HELP US WORK TOWARDS OUR
CLIMATE GOALS. EXPANDING THIS
PROGRAM TO AB FLEETS IS A SMART
WAY TO CONTINUE THIS WORK WAS
SUPPORTING JOBS THAT BUILD AND
MAINTAIN DECEMBER STRUCTURE.
THIS BILL BUILT ON IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION PASSED INTO LAW LAST
YEAR. WITH THE SUPPORT OF LABOR
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERS NAVY
LEADERS REQUIRING YOU IT'S
HONESTLY. TO BE ZERO EMISSION BY
TWENTY THIRTY. I UNDERSTAND THAT
SOME IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
OUR CENTER POSITION ON HIGH
LEVEL ARGUMENTS ON AV TECHNOLOGY
IN GENERAL HOWEVER RESPECTFULLY
MUST NOTE THAT THIS BILL IS NOT
WHETHER TO PERMIT A TECHNOLOGY
CALIFORNIA. THERE'S CURRENTLY
THE PURVIEW OF THE DMV AND THE
CPC. SENATE BILL TWELVE FIFTY
EIGHT WILL HELP CALIFORNIA TO
MAKE TANGIBLE STRIDES TOWARDS
CLIMATE GOALS AND SUPPORT JOBS
AND BY DOING THIS INSURER MORE
RESILIENT FUTURE FOR CALIFORNIA.
FOR THESE REASONS ARE STRICTLY
ASCARI VOTE. OKAY THANK YOU WILL
NOW MOVE TO ANYONE WANTING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF HEARINGS AND TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS- THE CHAIR OF MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED. AMOUNT OF TIME- AND
ALL OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY
MUSLIMS LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO
THEIR NAME AFFILIATION A
POSITION ON THE MENU MEASURES SO
NOW WE ARE ASKING FOR SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT. LIMITING THEIR
COMMENTS TO NAME AFFILIATION A
POSITION ON THE MATTER MEASURE
ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY WHICH
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE. I DON'T SEE ANYONE SO
WE'LL MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR PLEASE Q.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. OF SB
TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE FIFTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS. ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME WHAT
BEGAN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AT THE NATURE
OF. NINE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
THIRTY NINE YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. M. OF ONTO
LINE TWENTY THREE LINE TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON LEE ANY
TARGET ATTACK THAT AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ALICIA PRIEGO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALCHAMBER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CHRISTOPHE BELLANCA HOW
COULD THIS VALLEY LEADERSHIP
GROUP IN SUPPORT. NINE FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I DON'T ACT ON BEHALF OF
THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATION IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN QUEUE FOR SB
TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT FOR SUPPORT.
OKAY VERY WELL NOW WILL MEET
MOVE TO SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
OF THE MEASURE WE HAVE AN
ORGANIZED A PRESENTATION IN
OPPOSITION WITH MATT BROUGHT
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS A
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL MATT ARE
YOU EITHER HERE OR ON THE LINE.
THANKS MISTER CHAIR MAC BROWN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL
I IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO SB
TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT I THINK YOU
KNOW WE DON'T HAVE CONCERNS
BROADLY HI JUST ABOUT A TIME IS
VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY BUT ABOUT THE
PRECEDENT OF CREATING.
LEGIBILITY UNDER PROGRAM FOR
TECHNOLOGY THAT HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO DISPLACE WORKERS
THAT'S A CONCERN FOR US IN THE
LONG RUN I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT-
THEY NOW THIS IS ON PAGE TWO YOU
WE BELIEVE THAT THERE IS ALREADY
CURRENT ELIGIBILITY FOR THE
FUNDING AND YOU KNOW THAT LEAVES
US WONDERING. WHY THE BILL WOULD
BE NECESSARY OTHER THAN THERE
ARE ONLY TWO COMPANIES IN THE
STATE CREASON WAY MAYO WHO ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING ON- THIS SORT
OF LIKE FLEET TECHNOLOGY THAT
WOULD CREATE ELIGIBILITY
PARTICULARLY FOR THEM AND SO FOR
THOSE REASONS- WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY. OPPOSITION TODAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NOW WILL GO
TO. AND OF THE MEASURE LIMITING
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION. AND POSITION ON THE
MATTER IF YOU'RE NOT POSITION
ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY WILL GO TO THE
MODERATOR ON THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE Q.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TWELVE FIFTY. THANK YOU MISTER
TURNER AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWELVE FIFTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
SB TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AT THE NATURE. NINE
TWELVE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BURST MITCH SNIDER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO IN OPPOSITION. WE HAVE NO
FOR THE LINES IN Q. FOUR
OPPOSITION OF SB TWELVE FIFTY
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
COME OUT TO THE COMMITTEE TO
HEAR FROM MEMBERS. ON SB TWELVE
FIFTY EIGHT IS THERE ANY MEMBER
DISCUSSION. ANY COMMENTS- CENTER
GONZALEZ YES THANK YOU- MR
CHERRY JUST WANTED TO ASK THE
AUTHOR- TO A QUESTION OF TIMING
THROUGH THE THROUGH THE CHAIR.
THANK YOU- JUST RELATED TO THE
OPPOSITION I KNOW. AS WE'RE
LOOKING AT- THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION AND HOW TO
MODERNIZE THIS AND OF COURSE
LOOKING AT. YOUR MISSION
TECHNOLOGY- HOW DO YOU ADDRESS-
JUST THE YOU KNOW CONCERNS OF
THE OPPOSITION IN TERMS OF.
THERE ARE A- THIRD SUGGESTION
THAT THIS COULD DISPLACE WORKERS
OVERALL YEAH- I MEAN THE AT THE
END OF THE DAY THIS BILL- THAT
WE SEE IS BASICALLY IT LIVE
LIMITS ELIGIBILITY TO PROGRAMS
THAT THAT ARE LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLES SO IT SIMPLY DOESN'T
IMPACT TRUCKING AND SHIPPING
WHICH IS WHERE THE JOBS ARE NOW
THAT THAT I THINK YOU KNOW THE
FOLKS ABOUT REPRESENTS I TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND THEY HAVE A KIND OF
BROADER IDEOLOGICAL SENATE
CERN'S ABOUT. AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES. AND I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING WE'RE ALL GONNA HAVE
TO BE WATCHING CAREFULLY AS THIS
WHOLE DEBATE CONTINUES. BUT THIS
PARTICULAR BILL IS JUST LIMITED
TO LIGHT DUTY. AND SAID THAT THE
TYPE OF JOB DISPLACEMENT THAT
HE'S TALKING ABOUT I THINK
RIGHTLY CONCERNED ABOUT IT JUST
ISN'T- HILLS IMPACTED BY THIS
BILL. WELL THANK YOU IN OF
COURSE I WILL SUPPORT THE BILL
AND I APPRECIATE YOU- YOU KNOW-
OF ANSWERING THAT I DO YOU SHARE
THOSE CONCERNS YOU KNOW WE HAVE
TASK FORCES THAT ARE
SPECIFICALLY LOOKING AT THAT AGE
YOU DON'T HAVE STAKEHOLDERS THAT
ARE BOTH LABOR AND BUSINESS
LOOKING AT- ATOMIC ALLERGY AND
JUST. WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE FOR
THE FUTURE AND SO- WOULD LOVE TO
JUST KEEP CONTINUE WORKING WITH
YOU AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
CLEAN TRANSFER ABSOLUTE GRAHAM
HAD ALSO SENT A LETTER AND I
WELCOME THAT THANK YOU CENTER
HERTZBERG IN AND BEFORE CENTER
HERTZBERG SPEAKS JUST TO. EXPAND
ON THAT ANSWER HAVING SERVED
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE WORK ON
EARLY- PROBABLY ABOUT TEN YEARS
AGO THE EX CREDIT ON MACHINERY
AND I ARGUED- THAT. PUTTING A
TAX ON- THAT PLATE REPLACES
WORKERS WASN'T REALLY. A GOOD
THING FOR CALIFORNIA WAS
ACTUALLY BACK THEN. THE LABOR
FEDERATION WAS PUSHING THAT AND
THEIR ARGUMENT WAS. THAT TYPE OF
POLICY ACTUALLY HELP TO CREATE
JOBS IN A DIFFERENT AREA ON THEM
THE WORKERS- THE JOBS THAT WERE
HELP. THAT WORD MORE- GEAR TO.
OPERATING MACHINERY. AND
MAINTAINING THE MACHINE- IN
THERE WERE HIGHERPAYING JOBS SO
ON THE ONE HAND- THE MACHINERY
OF CRATER PROFICIENCIES AND THE
TAX CREDIT ACTUALLY WENT TO
HELP- CREATE JOBS. AND LOOKING
INTO THAT IT'LL BE INTERESTING
FOR ME TO SEE IF THAT SAME-
CONCEPT THAT WE USED TO CREATE
JOBS IN CALIFORNIA AND
TECHNOLOGY AND MACHINERY IN
OPERATION ON. THE RUNNING OF
THAT EQUIPMENT. WILL ALSO-
TRANSLATE INTO THIS- TECHNOLOGY
AS WELL BECAUSE OF COURSE YOU
KNOW MAINTAINING THOSE.
AUTOMOBILES ARE JOBS AND-
OPERATING THEM EVEN IF YOU DON'T
HAVE A DRIVER THEY STILL
REQUIRE- A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
ASSEMBLY MAINTENANCE AND- AND
OPERATION EITHER THROUGH REMOTE
MEANS. SO AT THAT'LL BE
INTERESTING TO LOOK AT AS THIS
BILL ADVANCES WHAT IF IT DOES
TODAY- THAT'LL BE- SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT WITH
RELATION TO THIS BILL. CENTER
HERTZBERG COULD YOU WANNA I DID
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR. BUT IT'S
NOT REALLY A SPECIFIC COMMENT
ABOUT THIS BILL BUT MORE BROADLY
AS WE ENGAGE IN THIS LARGER
DISCUSSION OF. A TRANSITION. YOU
KNOW HERE'S ANOTHER BILL WE'RE
GONNA WE TALK ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN VEHICLE CHARGING
STATION INFRASTRUCTURE SET
FORTH. ON PAGE SIX. LINE TWENTY
SEVEN THE ITALICIZED NEW
LANGUAGE WELL THE REALITY IS
THAT AND IT'S JUST KIND OF FACES
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE GETS INCLUDED IN THESE
DISCUSSIONS. WE'VE GOTTA CONVERT
THESE TRANSFORMERS WE'VE GOT TO
BUILD THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
HANDLE THIS STUFF AND SO WE TIME
AND TIME AGAIN OUR SENIOR PLAN
SMALL BALL AROUND THESE REAL
ELEMENTS AND THE BASIC BACKBONE
OF THIS CONVERSION NEEDS TO BE
BUILT. AND I JUST THINK AS WE
ENGAGE IN THIS MOVEMENT FORWARD
I DON'T WANT TO EVER FORGET AND
I'M GONNA REPEAT EVERY
DISCUSSION IN THIS COMMITTEE AND
BEYOND. THAT WE NEED TO DEAL
WITH THE UNDERLYING
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT REALLY IS
REQUIRED IF WE'RE GONNA DO IS
SIGNIFICANT CONVERSION TO
ELECTRICITY AND THE BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT TAKES
AND I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
AS WE AS A LEGISLATURE ENGAGED
IN THIS. STATE OF CALIFORNIA
FOCUS ON THAT CLEARLY WE CAN IT
IS NICE TO HAVE MORE CHARGING
STATIONS BUT AT SOME POINT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WON'T HANDLE IT
AND WE'VE GOT TO BE THOUGHTFUL
ABOUT IT SO I JUST WANTED TO ADD
THAT. TO THE DISCUSSION. RIGHT
THANK YOU AND- SAID REPUTED YOU
WANT SPEAK. YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- THIS IS A BILL THAT WAS A
LITTLE ALSO OFFERS CONFUSING TO
MYSELF BECAUSE I WANTED TO ALSO
BE VERY. RESPECTFUL MINDFUL THAT
LABOR FEDERATION AND TEACHERS
ARE OPPOSE HOUSE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND IT AS WELL. IN TERMS
OF JOBS THAT I DID SPEAK TO THE
AUTHOR AND HE WAS. REASSURING US
THAT- IT WILL NOT GET RID OF ANY
JOBS BUT I ALSO WANTED TO
INTERESTS ON THE BROADER
CONVERSATION AS SOME. OF THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM- SAN FERNANDO
STATED I THINK ALSO THE BROADER
CONVERSATION AS IT PERTAINS TO
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES IS. THAT WE
NEED TO ALWAYS CONSIDER THAT-
WHEN THERE'S NEW TECHNOLOGY AND
WE FEEL THAT JOBS ARE BEING
COMPROMISED THAT WE- CONTINUE TO
HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS AND HOW
DO WE BRING THE WORK FORCE ALONG
WITH US I KNOW IT'S- YOU KNOW
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS WHERE
TECHNOLOGY IS HEADED AND WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT. IF WE DO
CONTINUE TO MOVE THIS DIRECTION
THAT WE SIT DOWN WITH ALIEF-
FEDERATION AND- THE TEAMSTERS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
OPPORTUNITIES THERE. AND WE NEED
TO BRING THEM ALONG WITH US AND
MAKE SURE THAT THE JOBS CONTINUE
TO BE THERE FOR THE WORK FORCE
THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO WE
HAVE A MOTION. OKAY HOWEVER MOST
BY MOTION CENTER RUBIO AND THE-
MOTIONS TO PASS TO
TRANSPORTATION. AND IF WE CAN-
CLICK CALL THE ROLL PLEASE JUST
DON'T HOW DID YOU WANT ABLE TO
SEE THE AND VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOU SHOULD HAVE A CHANCE REPLY
APPRECIATE APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION VERY MUCH I DO I DO
WANT TO POINT OUT TO MY FRIENDS-
THAT THE INFRASTRUCTURE-
INCLUDING THE CAR CONSTRUCTION
BUT BUT ALSO THE CHARGING OF
STRUCTURES IS CONSTRUCTED USING
UNION LABOR- SO THERE'S SOME JOB
CREATION OPPORTUNITIES HERE FOR
GOOD UNION- WELL PAID JOBS BUT
WITHOUT AYE WRISTS AYE I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION.
FRIEDMAN HAVE MORE WITH MEMBERS-
AND RESPECT SESSION ABOUT.
PLEASE FOLLOW. SB FOUR TWELVE
FIFTY EIGHT BY SENATOR ALLEN DO
PASSED TO TRANSPORTATION WESSEL.
WESSELS HI DOLLY. BAKER BORJAS
PORGES HI BRADFORD. DODD DODD I
EGGMAN. EGGMAN I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE MCGUIRE. MAN MAN I
RUBIO. RUBIO HI STERN. STERN HI. NINE A STIR. THE BILL IS THAT
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OF THE FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS AND WILL MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT BILL ITEM TWO SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE BY CENTER-
NEWMAN A BILL SLATED TO PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE HYDROGEN FUELING
STATIONS CENTER WELCOME. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER MEMBERS
I AM HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY TO
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF HIS FEET
THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE WHICH WILL
PROVIDE AN ONGOING ALLOCATION OF
AT LEAST THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY OF CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM FUNDING OVER THE NEXT
DECADE IN ORDER TO EXPEDITE THE
BUILD OUT OF A STATE WIDE
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE IN EQUITY
FOCUSED FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING FUELING
NETWORK. BEFORE I BEGIN LET ME
FIRST THANK COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR THOUGHTFUL ENGAGEMENT AND
COMMIT TO ACCEPTING THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS AS A FIRST STEP
TOWARD RENDON CLARITY ON
DEFINITIONS AND ROLES AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. AS YOU ARE
ALL AWARE CALIFORNIA IS NOW
FULLY COMMITTED TO THE AMBITIOUS
GOAL OF MOVING BEYOND GASOLINE
POWERED AUTOMOBILES BY THE YEAR.
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE TO TRANSITION
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT FLEET. OF
MORE THAN THIRTY MILLION
VEHICLES AT A PACE SUFFICIENT TO
MEET THE STATE'S TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE GOALS. IT'S A GENERALLY
ACCEPTED FACT THAT RELYING
EXCLUSIVELY ON BATTERY ELECTRIC
VEHICLES ALONE WILL NOT BE
ENOUGH. TO GET US THERE BY THEN.
WHAT BATTERY ELECTRIC CARS ARE
WONDERFUL AND STEADILY GAINING
IN BOTH PROMINENCE IN MARKET
SHARE THEY ARE ENFORCING NOT
NECESSARILY WELL SUITED. TO
EVERYONE OR APPEALING TO
EVERYBODY PARTICULAR APARTMENT
DWELLERS WHO MAY NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
COMMUTERS TO DRIVE LONG
DISTANCES. OR DELIVERY DRIVERS
WERE RIGHT TO WORKERS WHO DON'T
HAVE TIME TO WAIT FOR A BATTERY
TO RECHARGE AS CORROBORATING
EVIDENCE A SURVEY CONDUCTED LAST
YEAR BY THE UC DAVIS INSTITUTE
OF TRANSPORTATION. FOUND THAT
ROUGHLY A FIFTH OF OWNERS OF
BATTERY ELECTRIC VEHICLES-
DECIDE TO SWITCH BACK TO
GASOLINE POWERED ENGINES WHEN
BUYING. THEIR NEXT CAR. IF IT'S
TRUE THEN THAT WE WON'T BE ABLE
TO MEET EITHER ARE IN ROOM OUR
ULTIMATE GOALS AROUND ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE ADOPTION
THROUGH BATTERY ELECTRIC
VEHICLES ALONE. WE NEED TO
CONSIDER HOW BEST TO ENABLE THE
GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT OF THE
ONLY OTHER COMMERCIALLY
AVAILABLE ZERO EMISSIONS ON
MOBILE TECHNOLOGY. THE HYDROGEN
FUEL CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLE OR
FCEV FCEV PLATFORM. AS YOU'RE
ALL PROBABLY WELL AWARE AS A
MATTER OF POLICY CALIFORNIA'S
SUPPORT FOR INVESTMENTS IN ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE.
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE NEUTRAL AND
NOT ADOPT ANYONE PREFERRED
ALTERNATIVE FUEL OR TECHNOLOGY
POLICY HOWEVER HAS NOT ALWAYS
FULLY TRANSLATED INTO PRACTICE.
TO DATE ESPECIALLY IN RECENT
YEARS PUBLIC INVESTORS HAVE
PRIORITIZE THE BUILD OUT OF
BATTERY ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE. TO THE
DETRIMENT OF HYDROGEN FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH IS NOT
ENJOYED A CORRESPONDING LEVEL OF
SUPPORT. THAT TIME. CALIFORNIANS
CURRENTLY. LESS THAN 4% OF TOTAL
FUEL INTEREST SPENDING FOR THE
BUIL OUT. OF THE PLAN STATEWIDE
HARSH IN FUELING STATION NETWORK
FOR BOTH LIGHT DUTY OR PASSENGER
VEHICLES AND MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY TRUCKS. THE ABSENCE OF A
COMPLETE SUFFICIENT DISTRIBUTED
STATEWIDE HYDROGEN FUELING
NETWORK REPRESENTS A PRIMARY
BARRIERS TO THE MARKET VIABILITY
WIDESPREAD CONSUMER ACCEPTANCE.
OF A PROMISING CLASS OF ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES IT ALSO SENDS
A POWERFUL NEGATIVE SIGNAL TO
AUTOMAKERS CURRENTLY OFFERING
WERE CONSIDERING OFFERING NON
POLLUTING ZERO CARBON. FUEL
EFFICIENT AND AFFORDABLE FC VIS
IN THE CALIFORNIA AUTOMOBILE
MARKET. ENSURING THAT HYDROGEN
FILLING STATIONS ARE WITH A
USEFUL RADIUS OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES FOR WHOM THE EV'S
MAY NOT YET MAKES SENSE TO
COMMUTE DISTANCES. WORK PATTERNS
HOUSING DENSITY OR LACK OF
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE IS ALSO
CRITICAL TO REACHING BOTH OUR
DECARBONISATION AND OUR CLIMATE
GOALS. SB THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE
WILL REAFFIRM HYDROGEN AS A PART
OF CALIFORNIA CLIMATE SOLUTIONS
AND PLACE OUR CLEAN ENERGY GOALS
WITHIN REACH WITH THE PASSAGE OF
SB THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE. THE
STATE WILL BE ALLOCATE
SUFFICIENT ONGOING FUNDING TO
ACCELERATE THE BUILD OUT OF A
COMPREHENSIVE STATEWIDE HARJIT
FUELING NETWORK. BEYOND TWO
HUNDRED STATIONS MOVING TOWARD A
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE FUELING
NETWORK THAT MEETS THE SELF
SUFFICIENCY THRESHOLD IS LAID
OUT. IN THE AIR RESOURCE BOARD'S
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AB EIGHT REPORT.
TO THE ORGANIZATION TO RICHARD
OPPOSITION I WOULD SAY
RESPECTFULLY. THERE IS NOT YET
TRYING TO PICK WINNERS AND
LOSERS IN THE RACE TO
DECARBONIZE OUR TRANSPORTATION
SECTION.HI JUNE IS NOT ONLY A
FIVE ONE ULTIMATELY PROMISING TO
OPTION FOR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. IT IS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT TO ANY REALISTIC AND
EFFECTIVE PLAN THAT WILL ENABLE
CALIFORNIA TO MEET ITS OVERALL
ZERO EMISSIONS GOALS.
IMPORTANTLY SB THIRTEEN TWENTY
ON ALSO PROVIDES AT LEAST 60% OF
THE FUNDING SHALL BE USED FOR
PROJECTS TO COMPLETELY. OR
PARTIALLY BENEFIT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. AND THAT ALL
CONSTRUCTION FUNDING WILL BE
FUNDED WILL BE DONE BY SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKFORCE FOR THESE
REASONS I HOPE YOU'LL SUPPORT.
SB THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE TODAY
NUMBER RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. WITH ME TO TESTIFY OR
THERESA COOK THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR THE CALIFORNIA HUNDRED
COALITION. AND ADAM BRAY ALI
FELLOW HI JINKS DRIVER. AND
ADVOCATE. THIS YOU HAVE TO
PRISON INSTEAD WITH AN ORGANIZED
PRESENTATION WE'RE GOING TO
SPLIT THOSE INTO SO EACH WILL
GET UP IN A MINUTE AND A HALF
BEGINNING WITH TERESA COOK THANK
YOU SENATOR AND SHARON MEMBERS-
THE- THREE SCOPE WITH CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN COALITION AND THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS SIMPLE
ENSURING EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA
URBAN AND RURAL WHETHER YOU HAVE
A HOME AND OWN IT OR YOU RENT AN
APARTMENT OR IF YOU PARK ON THE
STREET. OR WHETHER YOU'RE ONE OF
THE 13% OF CALIFORNIANS THAT
QUALIFIES SUPER COMMUTERS HAVE
THE ABILITY TO TRANSITION TO
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE AS IT
STANDS NOW THE STATE WILL AND
ITS HYDROGEN FUELING NETWORK AT
TWO HUNDRED STATIONS AND WHILE
WE APPRECIATE THE TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION INVESTED TO
THAT AND BY TWENTY TWENTY SIX
OUR WORK IS NOT DONE. SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE INSURERS
THE BUILD OUT OF A STATE WIDE
HYDROGEN FUELING NETWORK TO
SUPPORT THE GROWING FLEET OF
FUEL CELL ELECTRIC AS
LESS THAN 4% OF SEVEN SPENDING
IS GOING TOWARD HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE FROM THE FIRST CC
WORKSHOP TO STATION COMPLETION
THE DEVELOPMENT PROCESS CAN TAKE
UP TO FIVE YEARS SO WITH YOUR
SUPPORT OF THREE. EIGHTY NINE
TODAY CALIFORNIA WILL BE WELL
POSITIONED NOT ONLY TO EXPAND
THE NETWORK OF FUEL CELL
VEHICLES ON THE ROAD TODAY READY
TO SUPPORT THE THIRD WAVE OF
VEHICLES MANY IN THE MEDIUM DUTY
SPACE COMING FROM AUTO MAKERS
LIKE DOGS VOLVO AND OTHERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR
COMMENTS NOW WILL GO TO ADAM
BRAY ALL LEAVE MINUTE AND A HALF
. GOOD AFTERNOON IN
UNFORTUNATELY DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO KNOW IF YOU CAN HEAR
ME SO HOPEFULLY YOU CAN. HELLO
MY NAME IS ADAM BRALEY AND EVEN
THE CITY OF ALHAMBRA WHICH IS
JUST EAST OF LOS ANGELES IN THE
STATE SENATE DISTRICT OF SENATOR
SUSAN RUBIO- I'M PERSONALLY. NOT
AFFILIATED WITH ANY COMPANY OR
GROUP. INVOLVED IN THE
DISCUSSIONS FOR THIS BILL.
RATHER AN AVID SUPPORTER OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLES ALL TYPES AND
ROUTE. WHAT ARE YOU ABLE TO HEAR
ME AND HEAR SOMEBODY BACK THERE-
AND WE CAN. GO OKAY THANK YOU
AND THEN. ONE JUST AFTER I'M
PROUD THAT CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF
THE STATE. I THINK THE BEST
STATE THAT LEADS THE NATION IN
THE WORLD IN SUPPORTING
ALTERNATIVES TO GASOLINE CARS.
BUT TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN I'VE
BEEN DRIVING A FUEL CELL CAR FOR
MY DAILY USE AND I USE IN MY
BUSINESS IS A REAL ESTATE AGENT
HERE LOCALLY. I TYPICALLY TRAVEL
FROM ONE AREA TO ANOTHER WITHOUT
THE ABILITY TO. TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF ROUTINE PARKING OR NO PARKING
SPACES THAT HAVE BATTERY CHARGER
SO. IF YOU ALSO SYSTEM REALLY
WORKS PARTICULARLY WELL FOR ME.
AND THE ABILITY TO RAPIDLY
REFUELLING DRIVERS ARE EMISSIONS
FROM. THOSE CARS TRULY AMAZING
STEP FORWARD FROM THE BATTERY
ELECTRIC CARS BAKER FROM ABOUT
TWO THOUSAND TEN. TO TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN. WHERE I HAD A
REAL DEPENDENCE ON LONGER
CHARGING TIMES AND BOTTLENECKS
CHARGING STATIONS. I HEARD A
DISCUSSION OF THE EARLIER BILL
THE QUESTION ABOUT. BUILDING UP
THE INFRASTRUCTURE FOR. BATTERY
ELECTRIC CAR CHARGERS THROUGHOUT
OUR STATE AND- I THINK THE FUEL
CELL SYSTEMS OPERATE IN A WAY
THAT WOULD ALLOW THAT. EXPANSIVE
GROWTH. WITHOUT BOTTLENECKS THAT
YOU MIGHT BE AWARE OF. SO I
WOULD REALLY ENCOURAGE THIS
COMMITTEE THE SENATE AND THE
STATE TO CONTINUE SUPPORTING
FUEL CELL VEHICLES BY PRISON
FUNDING. TO BUILD MORE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO REFUEL
HYDROGEN CARS LONGER TERM TO
REALLY PROMISING TECHNOLOGY. WE
CAN SAFELY AND SUSTAINABLY MAKE
A DIFFERENCE IN OUR AIR QUALITY.
ALLOW FORMER THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE YOUR- COMMENTS TIME
IS UP. WE'RE GONNA. MOVE NOW
FOR- SPEAKERS IS. OF THE BILL-
BUT THEY COULD PLAY LIMIT COM.
TO THEIR NAME. POSITION ON
MEASURES. TO HAVE ANYBODY HERE
IN THE CHAMBERS YES GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS MIKE MONEY
GONNA BE HALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT. GOOD AFTERNOON SILVIO
FERRARI AND THEY HAVE A REALLY
KEYED IN SUPPORT. HELLO MICHAEL
SCHMITZ FROM RE CARBON IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. ANYONE ELSE
HERE IN THE GALLERY IN SUPPORT.
OF THIS BE BUILT THIRTEEN TWENTY
NINE NOBODY WILL GO TO THE
MODERATOR ON THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR COULD YOU COULD YOU
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT THE END ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE GATHER
THE LINE NUMBERS. FIVE FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
CARPENTER ON BEHALF OF TOYOTA
SUPPORT. NEXT ONE MOMENT FOR
ANOTHER LINE NUMBER. MY FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS MARK BROUGHT MORE
TO SWITCH COMMUNITY
ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICES IN STRONG
SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
LINES IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE OKAY NOW WILL MOVE
TO SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION WE
HAVE A- A LEAD OPPOSITION
SPEAKER CHRISTIAN COURT BE- WITH
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION YOU
HAVE THREE MINUTES. IS CHRISTIAN
CORBIN HERE ON THE LINE. YES
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRISTIAN CORBY
AND I AM THE DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTRIC TRANSPORTATION
COALITION OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
COUNTY THE- AND- KELLY TO SEE
HAS AN OPPOSE POSITION FOR
REASONS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS HOWEVER WITH
THE AMENDMENTS THE AUTHOR HAS
AGREED TO TAKE WE'RE- INCLINED
TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION TO THE
SP THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE. WITH
ONE OF REMAINING RECOMMENDATION
BASED ON THE DRAFT AMENDMENTS
WHICH IS TO HAVE THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD COORDINATE WITH
THE ENERGY COMMISSION TO
DETERMINE. NUMBER PUBLIC
HYDROGEN FUELING STATIONS
NEEDED- AND THIS WOULD MAKE THE
BILL CONSISTENT WITH EIGHTY
EIGHT. I WANT TO THANK THANK YOU
SENATOR NEWMAN NSURE HUESO FOR
LISTENING IN ADDRESSING OUR
CONCERNS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AS WE SEEK
APPROPRIATE LEVELS OF FUNDING
FOR ALL ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
AND INFRASTRUCTURE TECHNOLOGIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I WILL GO TO-
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION HERE IN
THE GALLERY TO HAVE ANYONE. IN
THE GALLERY I WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE. IF NOT WE'LL GO TO
THE MODERATOR MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE KEY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. TO SB THIRTY TWENTY
NINE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE. NUMBER ONE AND THEN
THERE OF. YES WE WANT TO REMIND
THOSE SPEAKERS AT THEY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION. AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE DO WE HAVE ANYONE
YET. WE HAVE NO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN TWENTY
NINE. OKAY VERY WELL AND- BEFORE
WE MOVE ON. I JUST WANT TO GET-
SENATOR NEWMAN- TO- CLARIFY THAT
YOU'RE ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS.
AREA S. RESEARCHERS I SUGGESTED
AGAIN GLAD EXCEPT AMENDMENTS ONE
OF OUR MANY MOVIE FORD. OKAY SO
WE'LL GO ON TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS CENTER HERTZBERG. WE
HAVE A MOTION SHERMAN I I'M I'M
JUST WANT TO SAY I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL A PROUD TO BE
A CO AUTHOR OF IT AND- BUT WE IF
WE WANNA MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS
IN THIS STATE MAYBE OUR RELIANCE
ON ELECTRIC VEHICLES IS THE WAY
TO GT IT DONE BUT- I THINK IF
WE'RE LOOKING TO SCALE THIS OP
ONE BILLION CARS I JUST DON'T
KNOW. THAT THERE'S ENOUGH WITH
HIM OUT THERE FOR US TO GET TO
THAT POINT HI THAT MAY BE THE
CASE BUT I THINK WE IN
CALIFORNIA IF WE WANT TO LEAD WE
HAVE TO TAKE A PORTFOLIO
APPROACH WE HAVE TO BE DIVERSE
IN THE TYPES OF INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WE INVEST IN AND SO I THINK
THIS IS EXACTLY THE TYPE OF BILL
WE NEED HYDROGEN HAS A LOT OF
PROMISE. IT MAY NOT BE THE
ANSWER TO IT BUT IT MAY VERY
WELL BE THE WAY WE GET ON THE
CLIMATE CRISIS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR STERN. THANK YOU
MISTER AT TWENTY. GET SOME
CLARIFICATION I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT YOUR SON THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THAT. THE
BILL PROHIBITS THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD FROM ACQUIRING A MOTOR
VEHICLE FUEL SUPPLIER TO
CONSTRUCTOR FUND- PUBLICLY
ACCESSIBLE HYDROGEN STATION SO
IN OTHER WORDS. THE BILL IN
ADDITION TO THIS THE FUNDING
INCENTIVES AND CODIFYING THE
GOAL IN THE EXECUTIVE ORDER.
THAT'S THE PROVISION THAT'S MOST
TROUBLING TO ME BECAUSE WHEN WE
PASS ON A TWO THIRDS VOTE THE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PLAN AND RE
APPROVE THE SMOG FEE IN THE
VEHICLE FEE AND A NUMBER OF
OTHER FEES THAT FUND THESE
PROGRAMS. PART OF THE DEAL
STRUCK THERE THAT I THINK THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY
SWALLOWED HARD ON BUT BUT DEALT
WITH IT WAS THAT EXEMPTION THAT.
THE OIL INDUSTRY COULDN'T BE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE HYDROGEN
STATIONS THAT WOULD SORT OF ALL
BE PUBLICLY FUNDED. BUT UNLESS
WE HAVE THAT BROADER COMPROMISE
AROUND THIS THIS FRAMEWORK. IN
OTHER WORDS WITH THAT OIL
INDUSTRY EXEMPTION HERE BUT NOT
THE BROADER SORT OF FEE RE
AUTHORIZATION WHICH I KNOW THE
COLDEST MINUS BILLS EXCITED
ABOUT AND WE WANT TO WORK
TOGETHER ON BUT- THAT PROVISION
IN PARTICULAR FEELS LIKE. YOU'RE
NOT PULLING A KEY SORT OF
BARGAINING PEACE OFF THE TABLE
WITHOUT. SORT OF FIGURING OUT
THE REST OF FRAMEWORK SO I DON'T
KNOW IF THE AUTHOR WANTS TO.
COMMENT ON THAT OR- COMMITTEE I
MAY HAVE MISSED TWO IN THE
AMENDMENTS. YEAH IF IT'S
STRICKEN THEN IT'S A DIFFERENT
ISSUE BUT IT I CAN'T SEE FROM
THE AMENDMENTS OR FROM THE BILL
THAT HAS BEEN STRICKEN SO MY
PRESUMPTION HERE IS THAT WE'RE
VOTING ON A BILL THAT MAINTAINS
THAT EXEMPTION FOR THE- FOR THE
OIL SUPPLIERS SAID MY GETTING
THAT RIGHT THROUGH THE AUTHOR
THROUGH THE CHAIR. OKAY MIGHT
MAYBE NOT THROUGH THE CHAIR
MAYBE THE AUTHOR. I DON'T SEE IT
IN ANY OF THE- AMENDED LANGUAGE
IT IS JONES A MISS COOK- URUS.
YOU MAY MAYBE THE SPONSORS IS TO
RESTRUCTURE YEAH. THANK THERE WE
GO OKAY. I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT
THANK YOU SENATOR TERESA COOK
THAT'S A WONDERFUL QUESTION-
SENATOR STERN THE AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE PROPOSED BY COMMITTEE
TODAY DO NOT STRIKE THE
REFERENCE TO THE CLEAN FUELS
OUTLET. HAPPY TO ELABORATE ON
NOT ADVOCATE YOUR SAID. YES SO
THIS SENATORS THE INDUSTRY WOULD
BE EXEMPT FROM ANY CARBON
FORSMAN AUTHORITY THAT'S CORRECT
. CORRECT OKAY ALL RIGHT SO I'M
OPEN TO SOME OF THE OTHER PIECE
OF THIS BILL AND I THINK WE DO
WANT TO STILL FULFILL THE BIGGER
VISION AROUND THE TWO HUNDRED
STATIONS AND SOUNDS LIKE WE'RE
ALMOST THERE MAY BE WERE
EIGHTEEN AWAY OR SORT OF SHORT
BUT- THAT PIECE I DON'T HAVE AN
ISSUE WITH BUT- THAT PROVISION
AND I BELIEVE IT'S ON PAGE
THREE- IN SECTION ONE B. SO IT'S
FORTY THREE OH. ONE EIGHT POINT
NINETY I CAN'T VOTE ON THE
MEASURE WITH THAT IN THERE RIGHT
NOW SO- YEAH APOLOGIES I'M I'M
IF THE AUTHORS OPEN HAPPY TO
WORK THROUGH IT BUT- THAT FEELS
TO ME LIKE. TAKEN A VERY
IMPORTANT PROTECTION WE'VE GOT
IN THE CLEAN AIR ACT- AND JUST
GIVING IT AWAY FOR FREE. ENTER
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- I TO HAVE CONCERNS WITH
pAT LENGTH WITH THE AUTHOR AND I
APPRECIATE HIS- YOU KNOW JUST
BEING ABLE TO DEBATE THIS THIS
ISSUE I WILL ACTUALLY SEE THIS
BILL IN MY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE- SOON SO I WON'T GO
INTO TOO MUCH DETAIL BUT AT THE
AT THE FRONT OF IT- WE KNOW THAT
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION-
THE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS OBVIOUSLY LIMITED
FUNDS- THE SUNSET IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. AND SO RIGHT NOW AS
IT STANDS AND THERE HAVE BEEN
DEBATES ABOUT REALLY RE
INSTATING THE FUNDS- AND WHAT
THAT WOULD LOOK LIKE AND I'M
GLAD THAT THERE'S AN EQUITY
COMPONENT IN THIS BUT RUN SURE
AS OF NOW ON THE FUNDING IN THE
MECHANISM FOR THE FUNDING SO
WITHOUT THAT- I WON'T BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY- AND
WOULD LOVE TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS WITH MY COLLEAGUES
TO BE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
CAN- REINSTATE THE FUND AND IF
WE DO WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE- IN
ADDITION TO OUR EFFORTS THAT'S
BECAUSE YOU'RE A MISSION.
INTELLIGENCE OF THANK YOU. SEVEN
NINE SERVICES WELL AT ANYONE
ELSE. LOOK IN THE COMMITTEE WILL
COME BACK. TO THE AUTHOR WE HAVE
A MOTION BY CENTER HERTZBERG. OF
APPROVED WITH AMENDMENTS DID YOU
WANNA MAKE CLOSING COMMENTS
THANK YOU MISTER SAID TO SENATOR
DOES I CAN DIE DO APPRECIATE
YOUR CONCERN IS TO. HOW WE
ALLOCATE LIMITED RESOURCES I
THINK UNITED WE THAT WE NEED TO
RE AUTHORIZE THE CLEAN
TRANSLATION FUNDING- THAT SOME
APPRECIABLE LEVEL I THINK THE
STATE'S FISCAL POSITION- AND
ALSO THE YOU KNOW BUT SHALL
APPROACH WILL SUPPORT THAT- TO
SEND RESTAURANTS POINT WITH THE
NUMBER OF STATIONS IT'S IT IS IN
FACT NOT TRUE- THAT WE'RE
HEADED. QUICKLY TWO HUNDRED AND
THIS IS IN FACT THE BASIS OF
THIS BILL. WHAT WE'RE DOING TO
DO HERE IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T DO EXACTLY- WHAT SEEMS TO
CONCERN. SO THE OPPONENT THE
OPPOSITION- IS TO CREATE
STRANDED ASSETS WE'RE AT A POINT
RIGHT NOW IN THE EVOLUTION. OF
THIS. VERY IMPORTANT PLATFORM
FOR ZERO EMISSIONS VEHICLES.
AGAIN AS I STATED I THINK IS
MOST PEOPLE ACCEPT THAT WE
CANNOT GET. TO A TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE GOALS WITHOUT GIVING
CONSUMERS AT LEAST TWO OPTIONS.
ONE OF THE OPTIONS IS
NECESSARILY.HYDROGEN AND FUEL
CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLES. AND TO
DO THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE SUFFICIENT NUMBERS
STATIONS THAT ARE PROPERLY
DISTRIBUTED. THAT ARE WITHIN
EASY REACH. OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. THIS IS EXACTLY
WHAT THIS BILL ENDEAVORS TO DO I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING. WITH
EVERYBODY ASSIST MOVES FORWARD
IT'S ESPECIALLY WITH LIKE FELLOW
MEMBERS OF THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE WITH THAT. I ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. VERY WELL- CLICK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION. SB THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE BY
SENATOR NEWMAN DO PASSED TO BE
AMENDED INTO TRANSPORTATION
WESSEL BY WESSEL HI DOLLY BAKER
. GORGEOUS OR JUST BY BRADFORD
RADFORD I DON. DODD AYE EGGMAN
EGGMAN HI GONZALEZ. GROW
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG BY MCGUIRE.
MAN MAN HI RUBIO. RUBIO HI STERN
. STERN STERN NO. OKAY THAT HAS
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTER NEWMAN WILL MOVE ON
TO OUR OF THE THIRD ITEM ON OUR
CALENDAR. WELL WHILE WE'RE AT IT
WHILE HE'S COMING TO THE PODIUM
COULD WHAT I COULD ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR DR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MOTION ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR FOR SB
TWELVE THIRTEEN BY SENATOR
WESSEL SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
BY SENATOR WESSEL. THE PAST TWO
PROCREATION WESSEL HI WESSEL BY
DOLLY BAKER. FORTUS BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HI DOT. DODD AYE EGGMAN
. EGGMAN HI GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I
GROW HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG BY
REQUIRE. MAN MAN HI RUBIO. RUBIO
FIVE STERN STERN I. THAT IS.
PORGES FORGES HI. THAT IS AN
APPROACH TO GET OUT OF THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS WILL
COME TO ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE BY CENTER
CORTESE A BILL RELATING TO
ELECTRICITY AND MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING LOCAL SOLAR PROGRAM
WELCOME SENATOR PLEASE BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. BUT TODAY I'M HERE
2% S. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE A
BILL THAT WILL EXTEND SOLAR
ACCESS TO LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN LEFT OUT OF THE
SOUL REVOLUTION PUT. MORE SOLAR
AND STORAGE ON THE GRID AT AN
ACCELERATED RATE. THROUGH
PROGRAMS SUCH AS A CALIFORNIA
SOLAR INITIATIVE PROGRAM THE NET
ENERGY MEET METERING PROGRAM THE
ROOFTOP SOLAR MARKET HAS GROWN.
HOWEVER STRIKINGLY LOW
PERCENTAGE OF THESE FUNDS WERE
RESERVED FOR LOW INCOME TENANTS
IN MULTI FAMILY HOUSING.
ACCORDING TO A TWENTY TWENTY
STUDY BY THE LAWRENCE BERKELEY
LABORATORY ONLY ABOUT TWO
PERCENT. OF RESIDENTIAL SOLAR
SYSTEMS WERE INSTALLED A MULTI
FAMILY BUILDINGS. THIS DATA IS
EVEN MORE ALARMING LOOKING AT
THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF LOCAL SOLAR
DISTRIBUTION WE SHOW THAT AROUND
HALF OF THE STATE'S SOLAR
ADOPTERS ARE IN THE HIGHEST 20%
OF EARNERS. ONLY 4% COME FROM
THE LOWEST 20% THERE HAVE BEEN
EFFORTS IN THE PAST REACH THIS
POPULATION SUCH AS THE MULTI
FAMILY AFFORDABLE SORE HOUSING
PROGRAM. KNOWN AS MASH IN THE
SOLAR ON MULTIFAMILY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- OTHERWISE KNOWN AS SOMA
PROGRAM. YET THESE ONLY SCRATCH
THE SURFACE OF THE AMOUNT OF LOW
INCOME RATEPAYERS THAT COULD
BENEFIT FROM SOLAR AND REDUCE
ENERGY BILLS. THE L. A. O.
ESTIMATES THAT OVER THREE
MILLION. LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
THREE MILLION. READ HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE CAN ASSUME
THAT A VERY LARGE PERCENTAGE OF
THOSE HOUSEHOLDS LIVE IN MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING. AT ITS FULL
CAPACITY THE SUMMER PROGRAM
WOULD REACH APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
OF THE THREE MILLION. WITH THE
PRICES OF ENERGY INCREASING AND
CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS BECOMING
MORE MORE DEVASTATING. THE STATE
MUST TAKE MULTIPLE APPROACHES TO
REDUCING ENERGY BILLS FOR LOW
INCOME RATEPAYERS AND GETTING
SOLAR AND STORAGE ON THE GRID AT
AN ACCELERATED RATE. SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE WITH THE CHI THIS
GOAL BY CREATING A PROGRAM. THAT
ASKS THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES TO BUILD AND OPERATE.
OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED MEGAWATTS
OF SOLAR AND STORAGE PROVIDE LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. WITH BILL
CREDITS IN PROVIDE RESILIENCY TO
THE GRID WITHOUT SHIFTING COSTS
TO NON PARTICIPATING CUSTOMERS.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THIS
PROGRAM WOULD NOT USE REPAIR
FUNDS. INVOLVED NO COST SHIFT
REPAIRS NOT PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM. WITH A MEMBERS SET TO
SHARE RECOMMENDED. WE WILL
CLARIFY AND ENSURE THAT ALL
COSTS WOULD BE BORNE EXCLUSIVELY
THROUGH A PORTION OF THE
REVENUES TO BE GENERATED BY THE
PROJECT THROUGH SALE OF ENERGY
AND CAPACITY. ADDITIONALLY I'D
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHTED THIS BILL IN
NO WAY WOULD IMPEDE THE SUMMER
PROGRAM. OR ANY OTHER PROGRAM
FROM CONTINUE TO OPERATE
APARTMENT OWNERS CAN CHOOSE TO
PARTICIPATE IN SOMA RATHER THAN
THIS PROGRAM. OR CHOOSE NOT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM AT
ALL IF THAT'S YOUR PREFERENCE. I
LIKE TO THINK THAT YOU'RE IN
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH ME
EXTENSIVELY ON THIS BILL. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO COMMIT TO TAKING
AMENDMENTS. TO NUMBER ONE REDUCE
THE SIZE OF THE PROGRAM TO
FIFTEEN HUNDRED MEGAWATTS. WITH
REQUIRED EVALUATION OF THE
PROGRAM AT THE FIVE HUNDRED
MEGAWATT MARC. PROHIBIT
ENROLLMENT IN BOTH THE SOMA AND
THE PROGRAM PROPOSED BY THIS
BILL. SO NO SIMULTANEOUS
ENROLLMENT. IN THREE ENSURE THAT
THERE IS NO COST IMPACT
PARTICIPATING OR NOT
PARTICIPATING CUSTOMERS. WITHOUT
SAID. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE- IN LET ME-
IDENTIFY THE WITNESSES- MR CHER.
HERE TO TESTIFY OVER THE PHONE
TODAY IS SCOTT WHICH ON BEHALF
THE STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS. ADDITIONALLY
WE HAVE MARK JOSEPH ON BEHALF OF
THE COALITION OF CALIFORNIA
UTILITY EMPLOYEES TO ASSIST WITH
ANSWERING QUESTIONS- I BELIEVE
MR WHICH IS HERE IN- MISTER
JOSEPH WOULD BE ON THE PHONE
LINE AGAIN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OKAY SO YOU WANT THOSE TWO
SPEAKERS MARK JOSEPH AND SCOTT
WHICH I HAVEN'T BOTH HERE IN MY
LIST TOTAL BE A MINUTE AND A
HALF EACH BEGINNING WITH SCOTT
WHICH- MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ACTUALLY SCOTT WHICH- I'LL BE
TESTIFYING ON. BEHALF OF BOTH
THE STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS AND THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION. HE TOLD
THE EMPLOYEES MISTER JOSEPH IS
AVAILABLE IF THERE'S SOME
TECHNICAL ISSUES THAT ARISE.
MEMBERS IT'S TIME THAT WE BRING
EQUITY TO THE STATE'S SOLAR
PROGRAMS. CALIFORNIA'S SOLAR
INITIATIVE THE CSI PROGRAM SPENT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS. TO BUILD
TWO THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF
ROOFTOP SOLAR. LESS THAN 7% OF
THAT THREE BILLION DOLLARS WENT
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING LOW INCOME
HOUSING. OR OR MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING TO DATE WE'VE BUILT
TWELVE THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF NET
METERING UNDER THE NET STATES
NET METERING PROGRAM TWELVE
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS. LESS THAN
ONE HUNDRED MEGAWATTS HAS GONE
TO DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
ORDER AFFORDABLE HOUSING OR
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING IT IS
SHAMEFUL. THIS IS AN APPROACH BY
SENATOR CORTESE THAT WOULD ALLOW
US TO BUILD UP TO FIFTEEN
HUNDRED MEGAWATTS OF ROOFTOP
SOLAR TARGETED AT CUSTOMERS WHO
HAVE BEEN PAYING INTO ALL THESE
PROGRAMS BUT RECEIVING NOTHING
IN RETURN. WE'RE ABLE TO DO THIS
WITHOUT A COST SHIFT. IT'S
ALLOWING A WHOLE SEGMENT OF OUR
POPULATION TO ENJOY THE SOLAR
REVOLUTION FOR WHICH THEY HAVE
BEEN DENIED THE BERKELEY SCHOOL
HIGH SCHOOL BUSINESS LAST YEAR
PUT OUT A REPORT THAT SHOWED
EVEN WHEN YOU ADJUSTED FOR
INCOME. BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN LEFT
BEHIND WHEN IT COMES TO SOLAR
DENSITY. THAT'S BECAUSE THEY'VE
BEEN REDLINED. THAT THE
UTILITIES AND OTHER CUSTOMERS
VERY WELL THEY CAN IDENTIFY
ECONOMICALLY THE TARGETED
AUDIENCE AND DELIVER THE ROOFTOP
SOLAR. IN RESPONSE THE SO MY
PROGRAM WE SUPPORT THE SO
SOMEONE PROGRAM BUT IT'S ONLY
GOING TO BUILD THREE HUNDRED
MEGAWATTS AS THE CENTER SAID
THAT JUST SCRATCHES THE SURFACE.
WE THINK THAT THIS COMPLIMENTS
DOESN'T TAKE AWAY AND WE WOULD
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS VERY
MODEST EQUITY EQUITY BILL THANK
YOU. I'LL LET YOU TO GO OVER IN
TIME BECAUSE I WAS INFORMED THAT
MARC JOSEPH IS ONLY AVAILABLE
FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. THAT
YOU WANT TO MAKE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. YES MISTER CHAIRMAN.
BACK REGARDING THE SOLAR PROGRAM
THAT THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
SO MY PROGRAM AND WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING IS THAT PROGRAM
TARGETS BUILDINGS AND THIS
PROPOSED PROGRAM TARGETS RATE
PAYERS. IN ORDER TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE SUMMER PROGRAM YOU NEED
TO BE A BUILDING A PROJECT OWNER
APARTMENT OWNER. WITH EIGHTY
DEED RESTRICTED PROPERTY WELL
THE VAST MAJORITY OF LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS DON'T LIVE IN DEED
RESTRICTED BUILDINGS SO WE'RE
TRYING TO GO AFTER FOLKS WHO
MEET THE ECONOMIC THRESHOLD THAT
WERE TARGETING WHO HAVE BEEN
PAYING INTO THESE PROGRAMS BUT
NOT ENJOYING ANY BENEFIT RATHER
THAN TARGETING APARTMENT OWNERS.
WE'RE TRYING TO TARGET THE
REPAIRS SO WE ARE URGING A VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW WILL GO TO- ANY OTHER
SPEAKERS IN THE GALLERY IN
SUPPORT AND THE SPEAKERS- MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL ANYONE OKAY WE'LL GO TO
THE MODERATOR MODERATOR PLEASE
Q. SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. OF SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE. THANK YOU
MISTER TURNER AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. NINE
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MOVING ON TO
LINE SIXTY TWO LINE SIXTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU- MY NAME'S
HUNTER STERN- WITH IBEW LOCAL
TWELVE FORTY FIVE MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK WE HAVE
NO FURTHER LINES IN Q. FOUR
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE OKAY NOW WILL GO TO
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE WE HAVE TWO
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION SO SPLIT
THEIR TIME. IN HALF EACH SPEAKER
OKAY A MINUTE AND A HALF
BEGINNING WITH RANDALL CIMARRON
WITH COMMUNITY ADVANCEMENT
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION AND I
BELIEVE HE'S ONLINE. MISTER
SIMMONS. YEAH HELLO MY NAME IS
RANDALL SERVING ON THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR COMMUNITY
ADVANCEMENT DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION. WE'RE ON OUR WAY
OUT OF FIVE OH ONE C. THREE
NONPROFIT THAT PROVIDES
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND RESIDENT
SERVICES TO LOW INCOME
PROPERTIES IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
ORANGE COUNTY LOS ANGELES KALYAN
KERN COUNTY. I BEGAN WORKING ON
THE FLOOR OF A HOUSE IN TWENTY
YEARS AGO AND HAVE BEEN IN
CHARGE THOUSANDS OF HORRIBLE
HOUSING UNITS. I HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE TO BE INVOLVED WITH
THE FIRST. CALIFORNIA'S FORMER
HOUSING SOLAR INSTALLATION COSTS
IN THE TOWN HOMES IN SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA. I LAST TESTIFIED ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR EGGMAN'S BILL
AB SIX NINETY THREE AND TWENTY
FIFTEEN. BILL CREATED THE SUMMER
PROGRAM WHICH IS NOW THE BIGGEST
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO A PROGRAM
IN THE COUNTRY. THE MAJORITY OF
THE RESIDENTS SERVED BY
COMMUNITY INVESTMENT DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION ALREADY BENEFITING
FROM ON SITE SOLAR SUPPORTED BY
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING MULTI
FAMILY LOW INCOME PROGRAM. AS
MOST OF YOUR WE ARE DEVELOPING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COMPLEX.
ANYTHING THAT ADDS TO THE
COMPLEXITY CAN MAKE THE PROCESS
WAY TOO MUCH. THE PROGRAM
PROPOSED BY S. B. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE MONSTER BIG UTILITY
BUILDING BIG UTILITIES BUILDING
THEIR OWN SOLAR ON THE ROOF THE
PROPERTY CYCLES WE SIR. ALONG
WITH UTILITY A QUICK UTILITIES
RULES AND UTILITY COMPLICATIONS.
I OPPOSE SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
BASED ON OUR HISTORY WITH THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SOLAR
INSTALLATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THIS APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY VERY MUCH WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO OUR OUR NEXT LEADER
OPPOSITION SPEAKER ESPERANZA
VIELMA. WHAT THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COALITION FOR WATER- AND
I BELIEVE- SHE'S HERE IN PERSON.
GOOD AFTERNOON- AGAIN MY NAME'S
ESPERANZA VEOMA AND I SERVE AS
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COALITION
FOR WATER I AM ALSO THE CO
FOUNDER OF THE STATEWIDE
COALITION THE COALITION FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL EQUITY IN
ECONOMICS ALONG WITH PASTOR
AMBROSE CAROL OF BRING THE
CHURCH. SEVEN OTHER VIRTUAL NET
METERING PROGRAMS ALREADY
PROVIDE INCENTIVES FOR SOLAR
ENERGY SYSTEMS FOR MULTI FAMILY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE PROPOSES A PROGRAM
THAT IS DUPLICATIVE AND LESS
DESIRABLE TO IMPLEMENT THE
EXISTING PROGRAMS. OUR PRIORITY
SHOULD BE TO ACCELERATE ADOPTION
THE WIDESPREAD COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT OF SELMA AND OTHER
SOLAR PROGRAM AND INCREASED
SPENDING TO REACH ALL QUALIFIED
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS ESPECIALLY
OUR MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS
WHICH MANY OF YOU SIR. JUST TO
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF CURRENT
FUNDING NEEDS AND EXISTING
PROGRAMS IN STOCKTON WHERE I'M
FROM YOU HAVE TO RESIDENTS ONE
FROM SOUTH SIDE STOCKTON NINE
FIVE TWO OH SIX ANOTHER FROM
NINE FIVE TWO ONE ZERO NORTH
STOCKTON THE NINE FIVE TWO ONE
ZERO RESIDENT DOES NOT QUALIFY
DUE TO THE FACT THAT THEY ARE IN
IN AS ZIP CODE THAT IS NOT
BENDED. SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
WOULD DILUTE FUNDS TO EXISTING
PROGRAMS AND ALSO ADD CONFUSION
IN THE MARKET WE THE C. TRIPOLI
URGE YOU TO OPPOSE SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU KNOW GO TO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE IN THE GALLERY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MARKS DIVERS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
WHICH WORKS WITH NONPROFIT
DEVELOPERS TO DELIVER AFFORDABLE
RENTAL HOUSING- IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND ANYONE
ELSE. WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
AND- MODERATOR PLEASE Q.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE ALL AND
THEY MUST LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS
TO THE NAME AFFILIATION A
POSITION ON THE MEASURE. THANK
YOU MISTER TURNER AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND
ZERO. NINE NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CARE WHAT IT THOUGH AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS ED
MURRAY AND THE PRESIDENT ABOUT
TAKE FULLER AND RICHER COULD
OVER I'M ALSO THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION. I AM URGING A NIGHT
VOTE ON SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
THANK YOU. NEXT BICKER. NINE
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH KIM STONE STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDER
AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. NINE
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MILLION MEREDITH WITH THE CENTER
FOR SUSTAINABLE ENERGY ALKALINE
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. NINE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI JENNIFER
TANNER INDIVISIBLE CAL ON BEHALF
OF INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA AGREED
TO THE MENTAL COPY FIFTY AYE
OPPOSED TO SELL. NINE SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
FRANCESCA WANDER I AM AT THE
NUMBER OF INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO
INDIVISIBLE HELLO IT IS BOTH
ACTIONS GO AND CALIFORNIA STATE
TRONG. WELL AND STRONG
OPPOSITION SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE. NINE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS HI MY NAME IS
PAUL WORMER. I'M CONCERNED THAT
I DO NOT SUPPORT FROM THE LOW
INCOME HOUSING COMMUNITY AND FOR
THAT REASON I ASK YOU
RESPECTFULLY TO OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS WRITTEN TODAY THANK YOU. NINE
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF TURN THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK I
APOLOGIZE WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION AND
LOOK FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE
AMENDMENT. THANK YOU. NINE
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ALEXANDRIA WITH REIMAGINE POWER
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF IT ENERGY
WHICH IS A MULTI FAMILY FULLER
BILLING OPTIMISATION CLOCKWORK
BRIGHTER IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE. NINE
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY SIXTEEN YOU MAY BE
ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS BECKY CARSON MA'AM I
OPPOSE AT THE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE. NINE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
KARINA GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF HIM
AND CLIMATE SOLUTIONS AND
OPPOSITION. NINE THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS SUSAN
DEMBOWSKI WITH INDIVISIBLE ROOTS
REGIS TONIGHT IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE SP THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE. MY THIRTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BACCHANALIA WITH INDIVISIBLE
SANTA FE AND CALIFORNIA STATE
STRONG GREEN TEAM IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK YOU
. NINE SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LIKE SIXTY
FOUR YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON EST JANUARY ON
THE HOUSE AND RUN IN COMPTON
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK.
NINE THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
STEPHANIE BROWN WITH TOGETHER WE
WILL INDIVISIBLE LOS GATOS
CALLING IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU.
MY FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
BRUNO HILL WITH SERVICE FIRST IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING
IN OPPOSITION TO SB. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE. NINE FIFTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS MICHAEL RIGHTS WITH T.
H. HOUSING I'M CALLING TO
OPPOSED SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
. NINE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON YOU CAN EXPECT A ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC. WHEN TRICKS COUNCIL
THE PARK WE CAN IF UNION
INDIVISIBLE EAST BAY AND A
WELCOME DEMOCRATIC RENEWAL CLUB
IN RESPECTFUL STRONG OPPOSITION
. NINE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DEBORAH
ELDERLY PHD AND I SPEAK AS AN
INDIVIDUAL AS A GREAT PAIRING
UPSET SON IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO SB ONE THREE EIGHT FIVE THANK
YOU. NINE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS DAVID SHEA WITH SIMPLIFIED
POWER CALIFORNIA BASED ENERGY
STORAGE MANUFACTURER IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO SB ONE
THREE EIGHT FIVE. WE HAVE NO FOR
THE LINES IN Q. IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE OKAY NOW
COME TO THE COMMITTEE TO ANY
MEMBERS WISH TO MAKE ANY
COMMENTS- CENTER EGGMAN. MISTER
CHAIR- IN THANK YOU TO THE TO
THE CENTER I JUST. SO WE'VE
HEARD FOM A LOT OF THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ADVOCATES AND
AS MENTIONED BEFORE- THE SUMMER
PROGRAM. IT WHICH STARTING BIG
STATEWIDE PROGRAMS LIKE THIS AND
AS WE ALL KNOW THIS IS DIFFICULT
TRY TRY LOOKING AT ALL ARE
HOMELESS PROGRAMS BUT WHEN WE
START BIG PROGRAMS LIKE THE CITY
A COUPLE OF YEARS TO COME ON AND
I CAN SAVE MY EXPERIENCE WITH
THE SUMMER PROGRAM. AUTHOR IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN WE COME ONLINE
UNTIL TWENTY NINETEEN AND
STARTED GETTING ALL THE
APPLICATIONS AND IT IS THE
PROGRAM BY ALL REPORTS IS DOING
VERY WELL AND THE PURPOSE OF
THAT PROGRAM WAS FOR THE
BENEFITS TO GO DIRECTLY TO THE
LOWEST INCOME CALIFORNIANS WHICH
IS WHAT. WHAT THE PROGRAM IS
DESIGNED TO DO ON THE ROOFTOPS
NOW THIS TAKES A DIFFERENT
APPROACH TO ANNA AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT AND I WOULD BE
WILLING TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR. IT SHOULD THIS BILL
MOVE FORWARD TODAY- BUT I THINK
THE REDUNDANCY- IN AND I THINK
AS- IT. ARE I THINK IT IS
POINTED OUT HERE THE SAVINGS TO
THE ACTUAL. LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS IN THEIR POCKET FOR
THEIR UTILITIES WILL NOT BE AS
REDUCE WITH THIS AS THIS IS
UTILITY DRIVEN AND- IN FRONT OF
THE METER VERSES. ON THE
ROOFTOPS WHICH WERE STILL TRYING
TO MEET THAT GOAL OF HOW MANY WE
CAN GET UP ON THE ROOF TOPS SO.
FOR THOSE REASONS AND I WILL.
BUT LIKE TO CONDEMN AGAIN IF
THIS MOVES FORWARD TO CONTINUE
TO WORK BECAUSE I THINK THERE IS
ROOM FOR ALL TO OCCUR BUT I
THINK RIGHT NOW- TO START. AND
SOMETHING NEW THAT'S UTILITY
DRIVEN AND NOT GOING DIRECTLY.
TO LOW INCOME HOUSING AND WE
KNOW HOW EXPENSIVE AND
COMPLICATED IS TO MAKE. WELL
HOUSING PROJECTS PENCIL OUT. AT
ALL THE DIFFERENT RESOURCES THAT
YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO USED. TO
BENEFIT- THOSE WHO WERE LIVING
IN THE HOUSE- IT'S COMPLICATED
SO. FOR THAT REASON I WILL NOT
BE ABLE SUPPORT THIS TODAY BUT
IF IT SHOULD MOVE FORWARD LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK.
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. IT IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE- CENTER REVIEW
. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I THINK
I WILL ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH
THOSE- WITH MY CALLING FROM
STOCKTON YOU KNOW IS- YOU KNOW
PREPARE TO SUPPORT THIS BUT YOU
KNOW I HAVE A LOT OF
RESERVATIONS- AND I'M REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE SAVINGS SAID
WORCESTER DATE EXPRESS AND I
KNOW THAT THIS SENATOR WAS THE
AUTHOR WITH THE ORIGINAL BILL
AND SHE- I. MEAN WE HAD A
CONVERSATION PRIOR TO THE TO THE
CENTER PRESS ANY RIGHT NOW AND-
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I DO
WORRY ABOUT IS YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU. SEE THAT COALITION OF
PEOPLE SPEAKING UP ON THIS BILL
AGAINST THIS BILL IS. YOU KNOW
PRETTY MUCH THOSE ADVOCATES FOR
LOW INCOME FAMILIES WHICH REALLY
CONCERNS ME- BUT YOU KNOW I
WOULD JUST SAY THIS TO THE
SENATOR I WANT TO SUPPORT THE
BILL NOW JUST BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
ABOUT IT AND I'D LIKE TO MAKE
SURE THAT. EVERYONE KNOWS WHAT
PRICE DOWN BUT A LOT OF CONCERNS
HAVE COME TO ME THE LAST TWO
HOURS AS WE ALL KNOW WE WEREON
BREAK AND- WE JUST CAME BACK
THIS MORNING AND SO IT'S BEEN
DIFFICULT TO TAKE. UP WITH THAT
IT'S GOING ON BUT- I DO WANT IF
I MAY ASK THE AUTHOR TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS BECAUSE IT IS
CONCERNING THAT THE LOW INCOME
FAMILIES MAY NOT. GET THE
BENEFIT AND- YOU KNOW IS
EXPRESSED EARLIER BY ONE OF THE
SPEAKERS AT MAY DILUTE THE FUNDS
ARE YOU AVAILABLE- AND- I WOULD
WANT SOMETHING TO WORK WHILE
WHICH IS YOU KNOW WHAT THE
CENTER FROM STOCKTON WAS.
EXPLAINING THAT TO HER BILL TOOK
A LITTLE WHILE TO GET GOING. AND
I THINK THAT THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR BOTH A SHE
STATED AND I AGREE. BUT I JUST
WANT ENCOURAGE MORE CONVERSATION
AND RELIEF- DISCUSS HOW TO HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE THAT THE LOW
INCOME FAMILIES BENEFIT FROM THE
SOUTH. AGAIN SENATOR I WILL
SUPPORTER RIGHT NOW BUT I HOPE
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO. TO HAVE
A CONVERSATION ABOUT IT THANK
YOU. CENTER HERTZBERG DID YOU
HAVE YOUR MAKE UP I DID. I DID I
JUST WANT TO CHECK. I KNOW THAT
THE MOMENT MISS. MAKE SOME
COMMENT ABOUT THE- THE SUMMER
PROGRAM. BUT I WANT TO GET SOME
CLEAR CUT EXPLANATION OF. THE
AUTHOR. BECAUSE YOU SOME ISSUE
HERE ABOUT. THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE SUMMER PROGRAM. AND
THE PROGRAM PROPOSED BY THIS
LEGISLATION. YEAH THIS THIS SO
LET'S SOLUTION DOESN'T IMPACT OR
INTERFERE WITH A SUMMER PROGRAM
AT ALL TO- PARAPHRASE- THE LEAD-
SUPPORT WITNESS- WE LIKE THE
SUMMER PROGRAM THE SUMMER
PROGRAM. IS NARROWLY DEFINED AND
TARGETED DEED RESTRICTED UNITS
WHICH ARE A FRACTION OF ALL. OF
LOW INCOME UNITS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT THAT'S NOT BAD.
BUT IT'S A THREE HUNDRED
MEGAWATT PROGRAM. THAT BY LAW.
BY THE ACTION OF. OF A GOOD BILL
THAT CAME FORWARD BEFORE. EARLY
TAYLOR'S- THAT APPROACH A TO
DEED RESTRICTED UNITS- THERE IS-
A HUGE PIE UNFORTUNATELY OUT
THERE OF NON DEED RESTRICTED
UNITS WHICH ARE LOW INCOME-
WHICH- NEED. NEED SOLAR THE
ROOFTOP SOLAR WHICH IS BILL DOES
ALLOW FOR BY THE WAY OR- NOT
ROOFTOP SOLAR- IN. IN IN EACH
CASE- IT'S A DIFFERENT BUSINESS
MODEL IN THAT. THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES HAVE TO PAY IN
BUILT IN THE OF THE THEY HAVE
THE SKILL TO DO THAT- THE OF THE
LIBERTY TO DO THAT- BUT RETURN
FIFTY PERCENT. OF ALL EARLY. OFF
THE GRID RIGHT BACK TO THOSE LOW
INCOME TENANTS UNIT BY UNIT BY
UNIT- SO. SIMILAR OUTCOME PEOPLE
ARE LOOKING FOR HERE IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT EITHER IN EITHER
PROGRAM THAT LOW INCOME TENANTS.
FINALLY GET THE ADVANTAGES OF
SOLAR- BUT A LITTLE DIFFERENT
APPROACH IN TERMS OF BUSINESS
MODEL AND ONE THEY'RE BOTH
THEY'RE BOTH OFTEN PROGRAMS TO
PRIVATE PROPERTY OWNER DOESN'T
AGREE TO HAVE EITHER OF THESE
PROGRAMS IF IT'S NOT GONNA
HAPPEN- SO I THINK THAT'S THE
BEST EXPLANATION I CAN. HAS
REMOVED MR A TO MOVE NOW IT HAS
HASN'T ITEM OF THE BILL THANK
YOU. OKAY SO THAT EMOTIONS
HERTZBERG. YES THAT'S A MOTION
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER COMMENTS
OKAY DID YOU WANNA MAKE ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS JUST A DAY TO
CURRY- A SERIOUSLY THE REQUEST
BY BY MY COLLEAGUES WHO SPOKE UP
ASKING THAT WE CONTINUE TO WORK-
WORK ON THE BILL RELATIVE TO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY OPPOSITION-
THIS THIS IS A BILL WHERE I
THINK SOME OF THINGS WE HEARD
EVEN FROM OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
CAN BE ADDRESSED- CERTAINLY IF
THIS IS SO MY PROGRAM NEEDS
OUTREACH AND ENGAGEMENT IN SOME
KIND OF N INFUSION IN THAT- I
THINK WE ALL SHOULD BE LOOKING
AT THAT TO CONTINUE TO GROW THAT
PROGRAM AS WELL WITHOUT IT
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
VERY WELL OKAY- CLARK COULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE BILL
WHICH INCLUDES THE MEN'S. SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE BY SENATOR
CORTESE. TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WESSEL BY.
WESSEL HI DOLLY. BAKER GORGEOUS
. BRADFORD BRADFORD I THOUGHT.
DODD HI EGGMAN. EGGMAN NO
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ HI GROWN
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG I REQUIRE
MCGUIRE FIVE MEN. MAN HI RUBIO.
RUBIO HI STERN. AS CHAIR WITH
ONE NOW HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET
OUT WILL KEEP THE ROLE OF THE
FRAPPES OF MEMBERS WILL MOVE ON
TO ITEM FOUR SB THIRTEEN NINETY
NINE BY CENTER WILL COST YOU A
BILL RELATED TO CARBON CAPTURE
AND STORAGE PILOT PROGRAM. A
SINGLE CASK YOU WELCOME BECAUSE
YOU READ SHERIFF THANK YOU.
BELATED EASTER GREETINGS- I WANT
TO START OFF BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. TO MAKE
THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE GRANT
PROGRAM CONTINGENT UPON RECEIPT
OF FUNDS APPROPRIATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND THINK YOUR
CONSULTANT FOR WORKING ON THEM
WITH MY OFFICE- BUT WITH REGARD
TO. CHANGING WHO'S IN CHARGE OF
THE PROGRAM I'D LIKE TO KEEP S.
B. THIRTEEN NINETY NINE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION AND
BY CREATING THIS- CARBON CAPTURE
GRANT PROGRAM IS C. ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT. THE S. B. C. RUNS AN
EXPEDITED ONE STOP PERMITTING
PROCESS FOR THERMAL POWER PLANTS
WE ENVISION WELL CEMENT IS
AVAILABLE FOR THIS WE ENVISION
BIO FUELS- AND NATURAL GAS TO BE
APPLICANTS HERE IN THE- YEAH
THIS IS THEIR JURISDICTION AND
IT CERTAIN POLISH BASS AND THEY
WOULD BE. AN IDEAL OF LEAD. ALSO
AN OUT THAT BILL TAKES WELL THE
CDC'S LEAD- IT REQUIRES
COORDINATION WITH CARB WITH CAL
JAM WITH THE WATER RESOURCE FOR
GEOLOGICAL SURVEY AND OTHER
GOVERNMENT BODIES- RELEVANT TO
CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE. THE
IDEA IDEAS WE DO THREE PILOT
PROGRAMS PARTIALLY FUND THE UP
FRONT COST OF RETROFITTING
PLANTS WITH CARBON CAPTURE
SYSTEMS AND CREATE A TASK FORCE
TO PROVIDE US WITH SOME
TECHNICAL AND POLICY ASSISTANCE
TO FILL OUT TO FILL THESE
MANEUVERING THROUGH THE CARBON
CAPTURE. A PERMITTING PROCESS
IT'S SIX YOU KNOW THE BILL. AS
BASIS WE HAD THE REPORT OF THE
LIVERMORE LABS SAID SAID IF WE
DID EVERYTHING WE WANTED TO WE
GOT EVERYBODY STRIVE ELECTRIC
CAR EVERYBODY'S GOT ELECTRIC SO
WE GOT ALL THE- BUILDINGS DONE
WE'RE STILL GONNA BE A HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT METRIC TONS. SHORT
PER YEAR AND WE DO DIRECTOR
CARBON CAPTURE WE DE
SEQUESTRATION NATURAL LANDS
REDUCE CARBON CAPTURE SO. THIS
BILL WITH THOSE FACILITIES ARE
REQUIRE ARE ELIGIBLE WOULD
REQUIRE MONITORING TO REDUCE
CRITERIA AIR POLLUTANTS. EMITTED
FROM THEIR- CCS- FIZZLED-
RETROFITTED FACILITY AND INJECT
ALL STORED STORED CARBON INTO A
HIGH QUALITY GEOLOGICAL
RESERVOIRS THIS IS MEANS THAT
THERE'S NO ONE. IN HANDS WILL
RECOVER WE KNOW THERE'S
OPPOSITION THAT WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE WILL RECOVER BUT WE'RE
LOOKING. ON A LIMITED BASIS TO
THE- CO LOCATED HIGH QUALITY
GEOLOGICAL- AREAS YOU KNOW WHERE
IT CRITICAL STAGE IN. R. FOR
CLIMATE FIGHT THE- REASON THAT
CAME OUT FROM AYE PPC SAID THAT
WE REDUCE OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS ONE POINT SIX. PERCENT
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN AND THIS IS AFTER WE
READ REACHED THIRTY B. THIRTY
TWO GOALS WE NEED TO GO AT A
PACE OF FOUR POINT THREE. THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY NEEDS TO
GO WITH SEVEN POINT 6% SO IT'S
ALL HANDS ON DECK- YOU KNOW THIS
IS THE- BALLOONING ACCUMULATION
OF CO TWO EMISSIONS. AND IS UPON
US THE REPORT FURTHER ON FURTHER
SAYS THAT BY DELAYING CLIMATE
ACTION AND A LACK OF NEGATIVE
EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES MANY OF
THESE NEGATIVE EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES RELY ON CARBON
CAPTURE WE'RE JUST NOT GOING TO
MEET THE PROMISE OF THE PARIS
AGREEMENT CALIFORNIA'S OWN
MITIGATION STRATEGY AN EMISSION
REDUCTION TARGETS ALL OF. ALL OF
OUR OFFERINGS AROUND THE PARIS
ACCORD. WE GO FORWARD YOU KNOW
THE MODELING FROM CAR SHOWS A
CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE TO RELY ON
CARBON DIOXIDE REMOVAL IF IT
HOPES TO REACH THE COMMON OUR
CARBON NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE SO EVERYBODY'S
TALKING ABOUT IT. I THINK THE
END END OF IT IS THAT WE CAN O
LONGER TAKE CARBON CAPTURE OFF
THE TABLE IF WE'RE GONNA FIGHT
FOR OF CLIMATE CHANGE IT'S A
SAFE AND EFFECTIVE TECHNOLOGY
DEPLOYED THROUGHOUT THE ON. THE
WORLD THERE'S CURRENTLY A
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE IT SCALE
FACILITIES THREE THEIR
OPERATIONAL AND IT BOARD
ADVANCING CALIFORNIA HAS.
CURRENTLY FIVE ANNOUNCED PROJECT
NONE OF THEM OPERATIONAL. IT'S
STANFORD IN THE ENERGY FUTURES
INITIATIVE FOR TWENTY TWENTY
REPORT ON CARBON CAPTURE ARGUED
THAT A LACK OF STATE SUPPORT
PERMITTING COMPLEXITY AND HIGH
CAPITAL COSTS OF ALL ACTED AS
BARRIERS TO THE- CCS SO. SB
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE ADDRESSES
SOME OF THESE BARRIERS THROUGH
FUNDING AND CONTINUE TECHNICAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN THE BILL
WILL HELP CALIFORNIA REACHES
AMBITION- EMISSION REDUCTION
GOALS AND I HAVE TO WITNESS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND I WOULD
URGE AN IPHONE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WE HAVE TO- ORGANIZE
PRESENTERS- AND SO WILL GIVE
EACH OF THEM A MINUTE AND A HALF
AS WE'VE BEEN GIVEN EVERYONE
ELSE BEGINNING WITH DR SERRA
SELTZER- FROM THE STANFORD
CENTER FOR CARBON STORAGE- IS
SHE HERE OR SHE ON THE LINE. YES
I'M ONLINE GAMING YES YOU COULD
BEGIN. GREAT OKAY WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR INVITING ME TO BE
HERE TODAY I STANFORD UNIVERSITY
AND IF I RECENTLY COMPLETED A
STUDY ON PCS OPPORTUNITIES AND
CHALLENGES I'D LIKE TO SHARE
WITH YOU A COUPLE FINDINGS AND
THEN ADDRESS HAD SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE COULD HELP
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
FOR CCS IN THE STATE. INDUSTRIAL
AND ELECTRICITY SET. OVER
HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION TONS OF CO
TWO PER YEAR. IN OUR STUDY WE
IDENTIFIED SEVENTY SIX SEPARATE
SOURCES OF CAPTURE BOTH CO TWO
EMISSIONS WHICH TOGETHER EMIT
SIXTY MILLION TONS OF CO TWO PER
YEAR. CAPTURE COSTS RANGE FROM A
LOW OF TWENTY DOLLARS A TONNE
FOR ETHANOL. TO EIGHTY DOLLARS A
TONNE ABOVE IT COMBINED CYCLE
POWER PLANTS. WE OFFER SAID
STORAGE OPPORTUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA HAS ONE OF THE
LARGEST GEOLOGICAL STORAGE
POTENTIAL IN THE UNITED STATES.
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR TCS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HUGE BUT SO
ARE THE CHALLENGES. EVEN WITH
THE FEDERAL FORTY FIVE PACKS
FORTY FIVE Q. TAX CREDIT AND THE
UP THE ABOUT. CREDIT ON ELIGIBLE
PROJECT. THE FINANCIAL AND
PROJECT RISK IT USED FOR ANY
ENTITIES TO CONSIDER TACKLING ON
IT SO. STATE DEPORTED
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS COULD
HELP OVERCOME THREE MAJOR
PROJECT BARRIERS. HI AT RISK THE
COSTS IN THE PROJECT EARLY
STAGES. UNCLEAR AND UNTESTED
REGULATION THROUGHOUT THE VALUE
CHAIN OF THE GPS PROJECT. AND
LACK OF PUBLIC. ACCEPTANCE OF
PCS. AN IDEAL CANDIDATE SITES
FOR A DEMO PROJECT WOULD BE
LOCATED AT OR NEAR GOOD GEOLOGIC
STORAGE MINIMIZING PROJECT COSTS
AND COMPLEXITY. BY ELIMINATING.
THE NEED FOR CO TWO
TRANSPORTATION. A LEAD AGENCY
COULD MANAGE THEM AND PROJECT IN
CORE. WITH INDUSTRY. OUR DATA ON
POSITIVE AND NEGATIVE RESULTS OF
THE PROJECT COULD THEN BE MADE
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE PROVIDING
VALUABLE LESSONS LEARNED FOR
FUTURE CCS PROJECTS IN THE STATE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL HAVE
NOW MOVE ON TO THE NEXT SPEAKER
IN SUPPORT FIELD SALES WITH
CALPINE- THEO YOU HAVE A MINUTE
AND A HALF REMEMBER CEO PAY US
REPRESENT IN THE CALIFORNIA
CORPORATION. WE BELIEVE THIS%
BILL ADDRESSES A CRITICAL NEED
IN RECENT OUR CLIMATE GOALS WE
KNOW FROM THE STATE'S ON
MODELING THAT WE WILL BE STUCK
WITH SOME OF THE SOURCES OF
CARBON EMISSIONS WELL THREE
TWENTY FORTY FIVE. WHY WOULD WE
TRY TO SEQUESTER THOSE CARBONS
AS MUCH IS PROUD TO BE POSSIBLE
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT THE BILL
PUTS THE STATE IN A GOOD
POSITION TO GET COMPETITIVE
GRANTS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. THEREBY LEVERAGING
OUR ABILITY TO BRING DOWN
FOLLOWERS BELIEVE IT'S WORTHY OF
SOME OF YOUR SUPPORT AND- WE
SUPPORT SB THIRTY NINETY NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS- NOW
WILL COME TO- SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE SB
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE IN THE
GALLERY ANYONE IN THE GALLERY
WHICH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SENATORS MICHAEL SMITH'S ON
BEHALF OF RE CARBON A NEW
INNOVATIVE OF A TRANSFORMATION
OF A COMPANY THAT IS- IS STRONG
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE. OKAY
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES NOW
FOR SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE AND AGAIN
WE WANT TO ASK- THE SPEAKERS TO
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME. FILIATION A POSITION ON
THE MATTER MEASUREMENT MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN NINETY
NINE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. NINE SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MADDIE MONTHS THEN ON
BEHALF OF THE AGRICULTURAL
ENERGY CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. NINE SEVENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LIAM BARRETT ON BEHALF OF THE
INDEPENDENT ENERGY PRODUCERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ONE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BONTA
HARTMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BIOMASS ENERGY
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT. NINE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS CYNTHIA
SALAD INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO
GREENSTEIN IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE
NO FOR THE LINES IN SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTEEN NINETY NINE NOW WILL
GO TO SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION AND
WE HAVE- NONE IN OPPOSITION AND
SPENCER'S ORGANIZED PRESENTATION
SO WILL COME TO THE GALLERY AND
THE SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO YOUR-
POSITION ON THE MEASURE PLACE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
VIRGIL WELCH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CARBON CAPTURE
COALITION- THE COALITION DOES
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THIS BILL BECAUSE
QUITE FRANKLY IT DOESN'T GO FAR
ENOUGH. AS HEARD FROM BOTH THE
AUTHOR AND MANY OF THE-
COMMENTERS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL C. C. U. S. IS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT THAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS
TO ACHIEVE. ITS CLIMATE GOALS
AND THREE DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS
ONE DIRECTION ONLY GOOD IS FAR
SHORT OF WHAT WE ACTUALLY NEED
THE REFERENCE TO THE- REPORT
EARLIER NOTED SEVENTY SIX
POTENTIAL FACILITIES THAT COULD
BENEFIT. I UNDERSTAND- WE'RE
JUST LOOKING FOR LIMITED
COMMENTS BUT WANT TO JUST MAKE
THAT POINT THANK YOU THAT'S FINE
THANK YOU APPRECIATED ANYONE
ELSE. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE
MONICA BEHALF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
OUR POSITION ALSO IS. OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED WE SHARE LANGUAGE
WITH SENATOR WHITE CASTING A
STAFF. DISCUSSIONS HAVE BEEN
VERY PRODUCTIVE AND WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO BE ABLE TO
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION THANK YOU
. EIGHT MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS GARCIA FOR THE WESTERN
STATES PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION
ALSO AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION. OKAY WILL COME TO THE
PHONE LINES NOW. MODERATOR CAN
YOU Q. SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THIRTY NINETY NINE PLEASE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE COMMENTS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN PLAN.
AND THEIR- AFFILIATION AND THEIR
NAME. PARDON ME AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN NINETY
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT THE
GENERAL. WE HAVE NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION. IN THE QUEUE FOR SB
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE. OKAY VERY
WELL WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE DO
WE HAVE ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. ANY- CENTER STERN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- TRYING
TO GET SOME CLARITY HERE ON THE
SCOPE OF THIS BILL. LOOKING
SPECIFICALLY AT. WHAT KIND OF
PROJECTS WOULD AND WOULD NOT BE
ELIGIBLE IF I COULD ASK A
QUESTION OF THE OFF- CENTER.
WHAT KASKY. YES WELL YOU WOULD
NOT HAVE ENHANCED OIL RECOVERY
WHICH IS WHICH IS. AS LEGITIMATE
CRITICISM IT DOESN'T GO ENOUGH
BUT YOU WOULD HAVE- NATURAL GAS-
SYSTEM. I'M GONNA SAY IS WRONG
REESE ARE SET TOOL CYCLE TO
CYCLE. AB BIOFUELS ETHANOL
PLANTS THAT WOULD BE THEIR
CEMENT CEMENT WOULD HAVE IT ANY
INDUSTRIAL PLANT LIKE I'VE-
HYDROGEN PLANTED THOSE WITH IT
WAS AN INDUSTRIAL PLANT NOT A
ENERGY PRODUCER WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE THAT THAT. A STEEL
PLANT I GUESS IF THEY'RE MAKING
STEEL HERE BUT THEY COULD DO
THAT TOO. HIGH A MATTER. SO IN
OTHER WORDS THE PROJECT COULD BE
ASSOCIATED WITH FOSSIL FUEL
PRODUCTION. BUT IT COULD NOT BE
ASSOCIATED WITH ENHANCED OIL
RECOVERY SO ALL OTHER KINDS OF
FOSSIL FUEL PRODUCTION BESIDES
ENHANCED OIL RECOVERY COULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR A PILOT I SEE SPELL
IT I'D SAY EXISTING INDUSTRIAL
FACILITY NATURAL GAS FACILITY.
BIOMASS FACILITY BUT- THAT'S ON
THE PRODUCTION SIDE ON THE SO
FEET ALLOWING FOSSIL FUEL
PRODUCTION BUT NOT ALLOWING EOR
IS THAT A FAIR STRATEGIES. OKAY
STRUGGLING WITH THAT- YEAH I
KNOW I KNOW YOU'RE TRYING TO
STAY LIMITED HERE IN SCOPE- IN
TERMS OF THESE FIRST PILOTS AND
OBVIOUSLY FOR INDUSTRY DOESN'T
GO FAR ENOUGH FOR ME OU KNOW MY
I WANT TO SEE SOME KIND OF.
FOUNDRIES ARE PARAMETERS ON THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE SIDE I SEE THE PROVISION
ABOUT REDUCING YOUR CRITERIA AIR
POLLUTANTS. AND WANT THAT TO BE
A LOT MORE RIGOROUS- OR SPECIFIC
BEFORE I COULD. WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE JUST
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T HAVE THOSE
SAFEGUARDS I'M I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS BEING CITED IN HOT
SPOT SIR. COMMUNITIES WITH
EXISTING FOSSIL FUEL PRODUCTION
SO THAT'S MY CONCERN I GET YOUR
WE'RE TRYING TO WORK THROUGH.
DETAILS AND SORT OF. CUTS
THROUGH A TRICKY POLITICAL. YOU
KNOW LINE HERE BUT I'LL JUST
RAISE THAT AS IS MY CURRENT
CONCERN. OKAY VERY WELL ANYONE
ELSE TO HAVE A MOTION. WE HAVE A
MOTION- SERMON DID YOU WANNA
MAKE COMMENTS. YES SO I'VE HEARD
A LOT OF CONFLICTING THINGS ON
THE VIABILITY OF CARBON CAPTURE
AS I THINK THIS IS EXACTLY THE
RIGHT APPROACH- AS AS A SORT OF.
THIRTY THOUSAND FOOT MATTER BUT-
I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
THE OPPOSITION IS STATE
CONSTRUCTION BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL AND I WAS WONDER IF YOU
COULD ADDRESS THEIR OPPOSITION
AND IT WHETHER YOU'RE WORKING
WITH THEM. THERE ARE A LOT OF
FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA THAT
WOULD BE IF WE LET EVERYTHING
USE CARBONCAPTURE THE- AT LEAST
THE IPC REPORT IDENTIFIES
SEVENTY SIX. WE'RE TRYING TO
NARROW THAT INTO WERE THE
RESERVOIR FOR THE WELL THAT THAT
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE IF THEY
IN FACT IS GOING TO BE COLOCATED
THERE THAT'S WHAT WE ONLY HAVE
THREE IN THE PLANT NOW NOW SOME
OF IT IF IT WORK. IN OF NANCY
SKINNER HAS A BILL THAT ONLY
FOCUSES ON ON CEMENT BUT CEMENT
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE IF THEY WANTED
TO DO THAT SO THERE'S A QUESTION
OF WHERE THAT CEMENT PLANT WOULD
BE TO A RESERVOIR PROBABLY NOT.
COLOCATED SO THAT'S THE THAT'S
THE LIMIT- YOU KNOW WE- THE
POTENTIAL IS GREAT I MEAN
THERE'S A LOT OF CARBON CAPTURE
GOING AROUND. THE COUNTRY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PUT. BUDGET
DEL INTO A TWO SO THE IDEA IS
THAT WE WOULD. THROUGH THE
BUDGET. PROCEDURE PUTS SOME
MONEY IN THERE SO AT LEAST
THESE. WORK COMPETITIVE TO FIND
OUT WHAT THE BENEFIT IS THAT
MIGHT MIGHT. ROSS THIS WAS THAT
WE COULD TAKE. ADVANTAGE OF THE
BEST PLACES NOT BETTER
COMPROMISED BY EARTHQUAKES NOT A
COMPROMISE THERE'S IT'S- A VERY
MODEST STEP CONSIDERING THAT
THERE IS SO MANY. LOCATIONS THAT
ARE POSSIBLE. AND SO YOU'RE A
SAID I DIDN'T QUITE UNDERSTAND
ARE YOU WORKING WITH OPPOSITION
THEN OR ARE YOU. TO TRY TO
SWITCH YEAH YEAH I MEAN THE IDEA
OF COURSE UNITED AGAIN I'M
TRYING TO THREAD THE NEEDLE ON
SOMETHING THAT'S ENVIRONMENTALLY
RESPONSIBLE AND DOESN'T
INCREASE. PARTICULATES IN THE
AREA AND ACTUALLY REDUCES.
REDUCES SAID. REDUCES THE AMOUNT
OF CO TWO THAT'S IT'S OUT THERE
FIRST IS DOING EVERYTHING AND
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH MONEY
TO DO EVERYTHING I APPRECIATE
THE THOUGHTFUL APPROACHING YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE IN SO WITH
THAT I WILL SUPPORT. OKAY SO WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR DODD
DID YOU WANT TO MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS ARE WILL CASCADE. NOT
RESPECTFULLY URGE AND I THOUGHT
I'LL CONTINUE TO KEEP THE- ACT
THE COMMITTEE- INVOLVE THESE
THESE THREE PROPOSED BILLS ARE
GOING AND SO WE'LL SEE WHAT GETS
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE VERY GOOD
OKAY OF COURSE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ON THE BILL DID PASS. AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. SB
THIRTY NINETY NINE BY SENATOR
WITH HOUSEKI. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL. HI WITH
SO HI DOLLY BAKER. PORGES
BRADFORD BRADFORD FIVE DOT. DODD
AYE EGGMAN. EGGMAN HI GONZALEZ.
GROSS HERTZBERG. MCGUIRE REQUIRE
FIVE IN MAN I RUBIO. RUBIO HI
STERN. SEVEN A STIR OKAY S.
SEVEN VOTES WILL- KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS- CAN
YOU CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE
MORE TIME. BURKE PLEASE AT
LEAST. HERTZBERG DOLLY BRECHER.
PORGES GONZALEZ GROSS HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG BY STERN. THE BILL HAS
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT WE'LL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR- ABSENT
MEMBERS MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
FIVE S. B. EIGHT EIGHT FOUR FIVE
SENATOR MCGUIRE- A BILL RELATED
TO ELECTRICITY EXPEDITED UTILITY
DISTRIBUTION AND TRANSMISSION
INFRASTRUCTURE. UNDERGROUNDING
PROGRAM- WELCOME CENTER BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS FIRST OF ALL MISTER
CHAIR I WANT TO TAKE MOMENT INTO
THINKING. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INCREDIBLE WORK ALONG WITH YOUR
STAFF ON SB EIGHT EIGHT FOUR AND
OF COURSE I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS TODAY. AT
MEMBERS SB EIGHT EIGHT FOUR WILL
PROVIDE A PATH TO EXPEDITE
UNDERGROUNDING OF ELECTRIC
UTILITY LINES IN THE HIGHEST
FIRE RISK ZONES IN THE CITY
CALIFORNIA. THOSE LINES ARE MOST
AT RISK FOR STARTING A WILDFIRE
LET ME JUST BE PLAIN THIS BILL.
IS GOING TO SAVE LIVES UNDER
THIS APPROACH EMBEDDED IN THE
LEGISLATION IS ALSO GOING TO
SAVE RATEPAYERS MONEY. YES THE
EIGHTY FOUR REDUCE CARBON
EMISSIONS BY STOPPING MEGA FIRES
BEFORE THEY START WE KNOW THAT
UNDERGROUNDING ELECTRICAL LINES
REDUCES FIRES BY NINETY NINE
PERCENT. AND THIS LEGISLATION
WILL HOLD ELECTRIC UTILITIES
ACCOUNTABLE TO THEIR TIMELY.
YEAH NOT ALL UTILITIES ARE
CREATED EQUAL THERE ARE SEVERAL
UTILITIES IN THIS STATE. THAT
HAVE DONE THE GOOD WORK THAT
THEY NEEDED TO DO TO BE A TO
MAKE THEIR REGION MORE FIRE
SAFE. AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THERE ARE CHALLENGES FOR EXAMPLE
WITH P. GENIE. OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS P. GENIES FAILED
AS CUSTOMERS AND MAKE
CALIFORNIA. UNSAFE FOR YEARS HE
DELIVERY UNDER FUNDED
MODERNIZATION WILDFIRE SAFETY
EFFORTS WHICH IS HAD DEVASTATING
IMPACTS YOUR IN THE GOLDEN
STATE. BUT I WANT TO BE CLEAR.
THEIR NEW CEO OR NEW CEO. WANTS
TO ESTABLISH A PLAN TO BE A TO
GET BROWN'S UNDERLYING.
UNDERGROUND AND I WANT TO SAY
HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE YOUR
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS BILL. NOW SO
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
WOMEN AND MEN FROM THE UTILITIES
WORKERS UNION WHO HAVE BEEN
ACTIVELY ENGAGE WITH US. AND
GRATEFUL FOR THAT CONVERSATION I
KNOW THAT'S GOING TO BE
CONTINUING IN I CAN'T SAY HOW
GRATEFUL I AM. OFF FOR THEIR
CONSIDER ENGAGEMENT. NOW
CALIFORNIANS OVER THE PAST MANY
YEARS HAVE LITERALLY RUN FOR
THEIR LIVES WHETHER HOMES BURNED
TO ESCAPE FLAMES FROM UTILITY
BECAUSE. WILDFIRES OTHERS. I
WERE UNABLE TO. IN OUR
BACKGROUND IN SPECIALLY IN
SENATOR DODD'S DISTRICT. THEY
PERISHED. YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER
YEAR THESE UTILITY BECAUSE
WILDFIRES OF CHARGE MILLIONS OF
ACRES OF FOREST LAND IN LEVEL
COMMUNITIES GENERATING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS EQUAL
TO MILLIONS OF VEHICLES ANNUALLY
IN TWENTY TWENTY ALONE THE SMOKE
FROM THESE FIRES GENERATED THE
QUIBBLING EMISSIONS OF TWENTY
EIGHT MILLION VEHICLES AND
BLANKETED MANY PARTS OF THE
STATE WITH UNHEALTHY SMOKE FOR
WEEKS. CALIFORNIANS HAVE SAT IN
THE DARK WITH FOOD SPOILING IN
THE WARM REFRIGERATORS FOR DAYS
ON END DURING WIND DRIVEN PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS AND
THEY'VE BEEN LEFT WITHOUT ACCESS
TO CRITICAL LIFELINE SERVICES
WHEN POWER LINES GO DOWN. THIS
IS BEEN OUR LIFE FOR LONG ENOUGH
IN CALIFORNIA. WE CAN'T ACCEPT
THIS IS OUR NEW REALITY- IS A
BETTER WAY AND WE MUST MOVE WITH
SPEED TO CREATE A PATH FORWARD
TO A BRIGHTER FUTURE. SB EIGHT
EIGHT FOUR WILL PROVIDE A PATH
TO EXPEDITE UNDERGROUND OF TEN
THOUSAND MILES OF LINE
ESPECIALLY WITHIN THE P. JEANNIE
UTILITY TERRITORY IN HIGH FIRE
RISK ZONES. CURRENTLY PG&E
UNDERGROUND APPROXIMATELY ONE
HUNDRED MILES OF ELECTRIC LINES
ANNUALLY SO HERE'S WHAT THE BILL
WOULD DO. NUMBER ONE. MANDATED
PERFORMANCE METRICS THAT WOULD
BE IMPLEMENTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
EXPECT TO SEE IF YOU SEE TO BE A
DEVELOP FISCAL PENALTIES FOR NOT
HEEDING TIMELINES. IN THE
UTILITY WOULD HAVE TO PROVE
SAFETY PROTOCOLS. ARE MET PRIOR
TO RECEIVING A RATE OF RETURN.
IT ALSO DEVELOPS THE PATHWAY TO
EXPEDITE UNDERGROUNDING
CONSTRUCTION BY STOP WISHING A
SHOT CLOCK FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
GOVERNMENT PERMIT APPROVAL
DENIAL TO JUST A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DAYS. THE LEGISLATION
WOULD SAVE RATEPAYERS MONEY
MANDATING UTILITIES USE
AVAILABLE FEDERAL INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDS CONSTRUCT UNDERGROUND
PROJECT BEFORE USING RATEPAYER
FUNDS. AND IT WOULD MANDATE THE
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES
UNDERGROUND UTILITIES IN THE
SAME TRENCH AS ELECTRICAL
UNDERGROUNDING IN THE HIGHEST
FIRE RISK ZONES. THIS DIG ONCE
POLICY WILL HELP AS A CASHIER
AND HELP MAKE OUR STATE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SYSTEM MORE
RESILIENT. ESPECIALLY IN THOSE
HIGH FIRE RISK ZONES IT ALSO
GUARANTEES A TWO ONE SEVENTY DAY
JUDICIAL REVIEW IN CALIFORNIA
COURTS. IF AN UNDERGROUND
PROJECT FACES A CALIFORNIA
BERMAN EQUALITY ACT LAWSUIT.
THIS LEGISLATION WILL FURTHER
REDUCE THE DEVASTATING IMPACT
THAT WERE SEEN FROM OUR CLIMATE
CRISIS. THE BILL SUPPORTED BY
CAL FIRE LOCAL TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY ONE WHO REPRESENTS
THOUSANDS THE HARD WORKING MEN
AND WOMEN BECAUSE- THEY KNOW
THAT DEFENDING OUR COMMUNITIES
AND RESIDENTS FROM THESE
WILDFIRES. ARE GROWING WORSE AND
WORSE. I WANT TO BE CLEAR ABOUT
THIS BILL. I'VE ALWAYS BEEN OPEN
AND TRANSPARENT. THIS IS A BIG
DEAL. AND WE'RE HAVING MULTIPLE
CONVERSATIONS TO GET THIS DEAL
DONE. WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH P.
GENIE IN THE WOMEN AND MEN WHO
ARE REPRESENTED BY THE ARTICLE
WORKERS ON THE LANGUAGE. IN THE
BILL AND WILL CONTINUE ACTIVE
DISCUSSION IN THE WEEKS TO COME.
WE'RE ALSO IN ACTIVE DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE TELECOMMUNICATION
INDUSTRY NINE. TRULY APPRECIATE
THEIR ONGOING CONVERSATION
COLLABORATION. WE'RE TAKING
NAMES TODAY TO ADDRESS A BIG
CONCERN OF THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY. AND I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS- NUMBER
ONE AND THEN MINCED ARE BEING
TAKEN TODAY THAT WILL CLARIFY.
THAT EXISTING MICRO CELL SITES
DON'T GO UNDERGROUND THAT WAS
NEVER OUR INTENT IN THOSE POLLS
WOULD REMAIN. IT'S COMMON SENSE.
NUMBER TWO WE ARE DEFINING WHAT
THE TARGETING OF LINES MOST AT
RISK OF FIRE ARE. THEY WOULD BE
LOCATED IN THOSE HIGH FIRE RISK
AREAS. AS IDENTIFIED WITHIN THE
MITIGATION PLANS ADOPTED BY EACH
OF THE INDEPENDENT- THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES- IN THAT IS IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. FINALLY
WE'VE TAKEN UP SEVERAL BILLS
OVER THE YEARS THAT HAVE SPURRED
CONCERN FROM THE
TELECOMMUNICATION UTILITY
INDUSTRIES. EVERY BILL WE WORKED
ON TOGETHER WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
STRIKE A DEAL THAT HAVE MADE OUR
STATE MORE SAFE AND ADDRESS
CONCERNS FROM INDUSTRY. SO FOR
EXAMPLE WE HAD SOME CRUNCHY
BILLS IF YOU WILL ON SB SIX
SEVENTY RELATED APPARENT THREE
FORTY. THREE FORTY ONE RELATED
OUTAGES THE BACKUP POWER. AND
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO WORK THROUGH
ALL THOSE CHALLENGES OVER THE
MANY MONTHS TO BE ABLE TO GET A
DEAL DONE. IT IS IT SAFER HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. SB EIGHT FOUR IS
A WORK IN PROGRESS YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK. THIS BILL WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS. AN INMATE
RIGHT HERE. THE WESTERN UNITED
STATES IS GETTING HOTTER. IT'S
GETTING DRIER THE THREAT OF
WILDFIRES IS ONLY GETTING WORSE
EVERYONE KNOWS THE ONLY PATH
FORWARD IS FOR ELECTRIC
UTILITIES A SPEED UP THE PACE OF
MOVING POWER LINES UNDERGROUND.
LIVES ARE LITERALLY AT RISK THIS
LEGISLATION WILL SUBJECT IS
SAFEGUARDED COMMUNITIES AND SAVE
RATEPAYERS MONEY AND THERE IS NO
OTHER CHOICE THAN TO SPEED UP
THE PACE OF MOVING POWER LINES
UNDERGROUND MISTER CHAIR I HAVE
WITH ME TODAY TERRY MCHALE
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA LOCAL
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY ONE NOW
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. OKAY WILL NOW COME TO
SPEAKERS. ORGANIZED PRESENTATION
SPEAKERS- WE HAVE TERRY MCHALE
WITH CAL FIRE LOCAL. TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY ONE. F. THREE
MINUTES MR MCHALE MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TERRY MCHALE WITH ERIN
REED ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING CAL
FIRE LOCAL TWO EIGHT EIGHT ONE.
THE FIRES OF THE PAST THREE
YEARS MISTER CHAIRMAN OR A
MATTER OF RECORD. WE'VE SEEN
MEGA FIRES CREATED THAT HAD
NEVER EXISTED. BEFORE TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
BECAUSE OF THESE FIRES MISTER
CHAIRMAN. ARE ALSO A MATTER OF
RECORD. WE KNOW HOW THEIR
BEGINNING. WE KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING THE COURTS TO KEEP
PEOPLE FROM BEING CRIMINALLY
CHARGED FOR IT. THE TRUTH IS
SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE DONE. AND
IT NEEDS TO BE DONE QUICKLY. I
WOULD SUGGEST MISTER CHAIRMAN
THE THIRTY YEARS THAT I HAVE
REPRESENTED AND WORKED WITH CAL
FIRE TO EIGHT EIGHT ONE. THERE
HAS BEEN THERE HAVE BEEN FEW
ISSUES MORE CONTROVERSIAL. IN
OUR VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
INDIVIDUALS GO OUT TO THE FIELD
AND TALK ABOUT THE PERILOUS
WIRES TOO CLOSE TO THE TREES.
THIS PARTICULAR SENATE SEVERAL
YEARS AGO A FARMER IN THE
SENATE. COMPLAIN THAT THERE THE
TREETOPS AND HIS AND HIS-
ORCHARD WERE LOPPED OFF THE DEAL
WITH THE PROBLEMS OF THE WIRING
OVERHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN. WE
HAVE FIREFIGHTERS WHO GET CALLED
TO A FIRE THE CAMPFIRE ALONE
WENT SEVENTEEN DAYS WITHOUT
ABATEMENT. OUR FIREFIGHTERS NOT
ONLY HAVE TO FIGHT THOSE
SEVENTEEN DAYS OF FIRE THEY HAVE
TO STAY IN THE FIRST IN THE
VICINITY TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
EMBERS DON'T REIGNITE. SOMETHING
CAN AND SHOULD BE DONE. IN TERMS
OF THE POLLS THEMSELVES THE
FIREFIGHTERS ARE EXHAUSTING.
THEY KNOW THAT THERE ARE OTHER
USES FORUM. AND RECOGNIZE THAT
THAT DISCUSSION WILL CARRY ON IN
OTHER COMMITTEES. IN THE FINAL
ANALYSIS MISTER CHAIRMAN WE ARE
GOING TO GO UNDERGROUND EITHER
WE DO IT NOW WE DO IT AFTER
ANOTHER FIRE SEASON WHICH IS
SCHEDULED TO BE AS PERILOUS. AS
THE LAST FIVE YEARS. AT SOME
POINT WE HAVE TO QUIT PAINTING
THE BUGGY AND PUTTING FLOWERS
AND RIBBONS ON THE HORSES AND DO
THE HARD DATE WE ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
WILL GO TO SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
OF THE MEASURE. OF EIGHTY FOUR
AND LIMIT YOUR OF. YOUR
TESTIMONY TO YOUR NAME FILIATION
A POSITION ON THE MEASURE. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS KATHERINE
BRANDENBURG REPRESENTING CINEMA
CLEAN POWER IN SUPPORT. ANYONE
ELSE IN THE GALLERY OKAY WE'LL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR
COULD YOU PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS. IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT EIGHT
FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
EIGHTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT THE END
ZERO. ONE MOMENT WHILE WE GET TO
THE LINE NUMBER.
NINE EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GREG COOK REPRESENTING
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY
IN SUPPORT. WITH NO FURTHER.
SUPPORT IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME SB EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR. YES
OKAY VERY WELL A NOW WILL GO TO
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE
AN ORGANIZED PRESENTATION TO
SPEAKERS- WILL CUT THE TIME IN
HALF A MINUTE AND A HALF FOR
YOUR LUNDA BENSON AND NIKOLINA
NONE THIS WILL BEGIN WITH YOUR
LAN TO BENSON. ARE LET ME SEE
HERE IS YOUR LAND ON THE PHONE.
ON THE PHONE OKAY WE'LL WE'LL
CERTAINLY ALONG BENSON SHOWS
FIRST OUR LIST- OKAY. AS PERCY
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
STILL ON THE FENCE AND
REPRESENTING U. S. TELECOM THE
BROADBAND ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA FACILITY
BASED WIRELINE COMPANIES. AND
BROADBAND PROVIDERS USTELECOM AS
OPPOSED TO SB EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR
FOR NUMEROUS REASONS STARTING
WITH THE EXTRAORDINARY AND
HARMFUL CAR ON ALL BROADBAND
PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA. THE
IMPACT OF THESE PROVIDERS ADDS
UP TO BILLIONS OF DOLLARS WELL
WE APPRECIATE SENATOR MCGUIRE'S
EFFORTS TO QUICKLY MAKE HIGH
WILDFIRE AREAS MORE RESISTANT SB
EIGHT EIGHT FOUR GOES FAR BEYOND
THAT. GOAL AND CREATES MANY
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. WITHOUT
CONSIDERATION OR DISCRETION FOR
SERVICE RELIABILITY OR ECONOMIC
FEASIBILITY SB EIGHT EIGHT FOUR
MANDATE. THAT BROADBAND
PROVIDERS WHEN SHARING A POLL
WITH ELECTRIC CORPORATION
UNDERGROUND THEIR EQUIPMENT I
SHOULD THE ELECTRIC CORPORATION
CHOOSE TO UNDERGROUND THEIR OWN
FACILITIES. UNLIKE THE ELECTRIC
CORPORATION TO COULD POTENTIALLY
RECOVER THEIR COSTS FROM THE
RATE PAYERS TO THEIR RATE CASE
PROCESS BROADBAND PROVIDERS DO
NOT HAVE THE SAME ABILITY TO
RECOVER COST AS WE OPERATE IN A
HIGHLY COMPETITIVE MARKET. AND
ARE RELUCTANT TO ADD SURCHARGES
OR POSSIBLE TO OUR CUSTOMERS.
INVARIABLY THESE COSTS WILL
EITHER COME OUT OF TWO PLACES
NUMBER ONE THEY WILL COME OUT OF
CAPITAL EXPENDITURE BUDGETS THAT
COULD HAVE BEEN SPENT ON
DEPLOYING AND UPGRADING
BROADBAND. IN SUCH CASES TO RULE
CALIFORNIA'S OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
DO NOT YET HAVE IT. BROADBAND
PRICES WOULD COULD RIGHTS
COUNTERING THE PROGRESS OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION BROADBAND
PROVIDER AND THIS LEGISLATURE TO
MAKE AFFORDABLE AND IN SOME
CASES FREE OFFER. AVAILABLE TO
LOW INCOME CUSTOMERS. WHAT MORE
WHAT'S MORE IS THAT THE HIGHER
COSTS WOULD COME AT A TIME WHEN
ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE NAVIGATING
A HISTORIC INFLATIONARY PERIOD
IMPACTING ALL GOODS AND
SERVICES. AT A MINIMUM BROADBAND
PROVIDERS WHAT THE DISCRETION TO
STAY ON THE POLLS AND WOOD
UNDERGROUND IN CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE IT MAKES ECONOMIC SENSE
THIS IS CURRENTLY THE PRACTICE
OF AN ELECTRIC CORPORATION'S
REMOVING A PAUL. KOSTER
DISCUSSED AND OFTEN SHARED WITH
COLLABORATION AND PARTNERSHIP
WITH ALL PARTIES I'M SORRY
DISPENSER MULLIN YOU WENT WAY
OVER IN TIME WELCOME TO THE
NICHOLAS. AND ON THIS- THANK YOU
AND IF YOU COULD PLEASE. KEEP IT
TOO AND IF I COULD REMEMBER
UNIQUE GREEN AND THEN THIS.
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS WITH ANY OF
GAS AND ELECTRIC- WE SEND SOME
POINT FOR THE OTHER BUT MUCH
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE- THIS BILL
SETS A DANGEROUS PRECEDENT AND
WITHHOLDING EARNINGS FOR FIVE
YEARS. ON A CERTAIN METRICS ARE
AREARE CHEAP COMPLEX WITH THE
CONTACT THAT WE HAVE WITH THE
STATE- NO PS PS OR WILD CARDS
IMPOSSIBLE STANDARD. THESE ARE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE NO CONTROL
OVER. REGARDING THE COLD LOOK
FOR THREE ISSUE AMEND. DON'T
PROVIDE CLARITY ON AND COST
RECOVERY THAT TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE COMPLEX
RELATIONSHIP WITH THESE OF
FACILITIES SOMETIMES THEY'RE CO
OWNED SOMETIMES THERE LEAST- THE
BILL OVERALL IS DUPLICATIVE OF
PEACE HERE READY PROVES
INTEGRATING PROJECT AS PART OF
THE W. W. M. P. AND THROUGH THIS
PROCESS WE HAVE A- HOLISTIC
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH WE TAKE A
LOOK AT COST BENEFIT- AND
FEASIBILITY- AND- THE BILL. I
WOULD NOT IN OUR OPINION
EXPEDITE WORK MAKE UNDERGROUND
MORE COST EFFECTIVE DUE TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND- PERMITTING.
PROCESS THESE. ULTIMATELY THESE
COSTS- WOULD BE BORNE BY
CUSTOMERS- SO RESPECTFULLY YOU
KNOW ESTY GENIE AS COMMITTED TO
REDUCING THE RISK OF WILDFIRES
AND WE'VE INVESTED OVER TWO
BILLION DOLLARS AND SYSTEM
HARDENING. AND COMMUNITY
RESILIENCY OF THE LAST FIFTEEN
YEARS AND WE APPRECIATE MANY
OTHERS COMING FROM AND ALSO
APPRECIATE THE STAFF FOR MEETING
WITH US AND HAVING VARIOUS
DISCUSSIONS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN OF THANK YOU. THANK
YOU KNOW. SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
IF YOU COULD LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS
TO- YOUR- NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURE. A
GALLERY MEMBERS MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GOT WHICH ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
EMPLOYEES WE ARE OPPOSED BUT
WE'RE SHARE THE OBJECTIVES AND
ARE WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BERNIE OROZCO
WITH CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE EQUALLY ADAMANTLY OPPOSE
PASSES WAITED PLAY BRIGHTON IS
ON UTILITY POLES. THANK YOU-
ANYONE ELSE OKAY WILL COME TO
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
OF SB EIGHT EIGHT FOUR. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT EIGHTY
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO. NINE
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NAY SOLO OF ON
BEHALF OF FRONTIER
COMMUNICATIONS OPPOSED TO LESS
AMENDED TO REVIEW THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PORTION OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI CAN TRY LANDER ON THE
HAPLESS CAL CALM AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB EIGHTY
FOUR THANK YOU. NINE EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN YOU MAY BE A NEW. I WISH
TO CREATE A ON BEHALF OF THE
CALCHAMBER AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH DR THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JENNIFER CAMERA
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA GREEN
SHE- OPPOSED THE MUFFIN MAN.
FIVE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IF YOU CONSIDER
THAT THE CALIFORNIA EDISON
ALTHOUGH WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE DAY WE THINK THE AUTHOR.
NINE EIGHTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHOPFRONTS
AND CROWN CASTLE WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH AUSTIN
THANK YOU. NINE SIXTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JONATHAN
THEIR BILL ON BEHALF OF THE TI
EIGHTY TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. NINE SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AFTER THAT THE. WE HAVE
NO RESPONSE FROM NINE SEVENTY
SIX. AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN Q. FOUR OPPOSITION
OF SB EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR OKAY
THANK YOU WILL COME TO THE
COMMITTEE NOW AND JUST
GENERALLY- IF I CAN MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS. RELATED TO THIS MATTER
AND THIS BILL HAVING HAD WORKED
ON YOU KNOW THE PG&E BANKRUPTCY
THE WILDFIRE ISSUE THAT- WAS
CHAIRED BY SENATOR DODD I MEAN
WE'VE DONE QUITE A BIT OF WORK.
RESPONDING TO THE WILDFIRES
MAKING WORKING TO MAKE UTILITIES
SAY FOR DEVELOPING IN- MASSIVE-
FISHERMAN'S FUND FIND A WAY TO
ENSURE THE- VICTIMS OF WILDFIRES
AMID THIS IS BEEN. YEARS AND
YEARS OF WORK AND- YOU KNOW IT'S
- DISCONCERTING TO BE KIND OF AT
THIS POINT- CONSIDERING
LEGISLATION BECAUSE IT'S A TOUGH
THING. TO WORK THROUGH WHERE YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE- UTILITY
CONTINUING TO CAUSE WILDFIRES
WHILE WERE- WE WE'VE GONE
THROUGH THIS PROCESS OF- YOU
KNOW HARDING THE WORKING TO.
SUPPORT AND FINANCE HI HEARTGARD
IN THE GRID RAKERS OF PAYING FOR
THAT. BUT THIS IS A HARD ISSUE
AND WE WANT OUR UTILITIES TO
SURVIVE. WE WANT THEM TO STAY IN
BUSINESS BECAUSE ENERGY OF
COURSE IS SO KEY TO THE RUNNING
OF OUR STATE. BUT HOW DO WE HOW
DO WE FIND THAT MIDDLE GROUND
WHERE WE DON'T YOU KNOW BREAK
THE BANK IN TERMS OF REQUIRING.
RATES TO SKYROCKET. AND AGAIN
THIS BILL OF WHILE IT'S A
STATEWIDE MEASURE. IT WORRIES ME
THAT A YOU KNOW IN PLACES LIKE
SAN DIEGO OR WE HAVE INCREASED
RATES TOO. HARD IN OUR GRID
WHERE WE HAVE CREATED PROGRAMS
TO FIGHT FIRES. THAT THIS SHOULD
EVEN APPLY TO SAN DIEGO ANOTHER
UTILITIES THAT AREN'T IN THE
SAME CATEGORY. AS PG&E AND I
KNOW PSG I MEAN THIS. DOESN'T
HELP THE P. JEANNIE CAME OUT AND
SAID WE'RE GONNA. UNDERGROUND
UTILITIES- WITHOUT REALLY HAVING
A PLAN AND WITHOUT RELEASED-
SAYING HOW MUCH THAT'S GOING TO
COST AND WHERE IT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN. AND SO THAT ADDS OF.
FUEL TO THE PER PER VIEW RUBIO
FIRE HERE. IN THAT- IT GIVES
RISE TO LEGISLATION LIKE THIS
THAT. THIS SIMPLY ASKING FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY SO THIS IS A
REALLY HARD ONE TO- TO BALANCE-
BUT AT THE SAME TIME THERE SOME
READ REASONABLE MEASURES IN THIS
BILL. IN ALL I WANT TO AUTHORS
WE MOVE FORWARD TO CONSIDER THE
PLACES LIKE SANDY WILL COULD BE
AFFECTED LIKE THIS- WE WILL
THERE WAS A LOT OF CRITICISM OF
SAN DIEGO RECENTLY AND HAVING
THE HIGHEST RATES IN THE
COUNTRY. IN IN IN JANUARY AND
FEBRUARY AND- YOU KNOW PEOPLE
ARE ANGRY SO. WE ARE WORKING TO
FIGHT FIRES TO CLIMATE CHANGE
BUT THERE'S A BREAKING POINT
WHERE PEOPLE ARE ARE SAYING I'M
NOT GONNA PAY FOR THIS ANYMORE.
AND WE HAVE TO BE VERY MINDFUL
AS A LEGISLATURE NOT TO PUT PUSH
THOSE CALLS. ARE TO OR COSTS ON
RATEPAYERS TO THE POINT WHERE
THEY'RE GOING TO GIVE UP. ON ON
THE FIGHT TO SOLVE SOME OF THE
CLIENTS MOST PRESSING PROBLEMS.
OF THE WORLD'S MOST PRESSING
PROBLEMS RELATED TO CLIMATE
CHANGE. SO- ALL ON THIS BILL- I
APPRECIATE THE- AUTHOR WORKING
ON THIS BILL WORKING WITH US BUT
AS YOU MOVE FORWARD I HOPE YOU
CONSIDER PLACES LIKE SAN DIEGO
WHERE WE HAVE ALREADY TAKEN
MEASURES TO THINK TO MAKE THESE
INVESTMENTS AND WHERE. YOU KNOW
UNDERGROUNDING NET ISN'T
NECESSARILY PART OF OUR
STRATEGY- AND WHERE WHERE IT
COULD DRIVE UP COSTS FOR OUR
REPAIRS WHERE WE CAN'T REALLY
AFFORD THAT AND I KNOW THIS IS A
WORK IN PROGRESS AND NOW YOU'RE
WORKING THROUGH SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT I WILL BE ANOTHER OR
THERE ARE SOME VERY REAL-
CHANGES THAT NEED TO MAKE THE
MAKE AND I KNOW YOU'RE HEADED IN
THAT DIRECTION AND I HOPE THAT
YOU REALLY GET TO. THE CRUX OF
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO SOLVE WILL
COME DOWN MEMBERS KNOCKED
APPRECIATE SEPT IN THE
MAINTENANCE AND- WERE
RECOMMENDING THIS BILL WITH THE
AMENDMENTS- COME TO CENTER MEN
FOLLOWED BY RUBIO THAN BRADFORD
AND IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE- AND
OUR DID YOU WANT TO SPEAK CENTER
STERN OKAY AND THEN FOLLOWED BY
CENTER STERN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I WANT TO ECHO YOUR
COMMENTS I THINK YOU SPOKE
ELOQUENTLY ON. THE TRADE
OUTSOURCING THIS IS A VERY
AMBITIOUS BILL- TRYING TO SOLVE
A VERY REAL PROBLEM IN THE
STATE- THE RISKS THAT ARE.
UTILITIES SUPPOSED TO THE
PROBLEM OF WILDFIRES. AT THE
SAME TIME WHO PAYS FOR THOSE
PROPHYLACTIC MEASURES I THINK IS
AN IMPORTANT QUESTION- HI I TALK
WITH THE AUTHOR EARLIER THIS
WEEK AT NIGHT I KNOW THAT HE'S
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
OPPOSITION COMMITTED TO BEING
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT SOME OF THESE
QUESTIONS. ON SO THAT I WILL
VOTE TODAY TO GET OUT OF
COMMITTEE- BUT I RESERVE THE
RIGHT TO SEE HOW THE FINAL
PRODUCT SHAPES UP- GOING
FORWARD- SO THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR HARD WORK MR MAJORITY
LEADER AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE FINAL PRODUCT. OKAY-
CENTER- WAS NEXT SENATOR RUBIO
WE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- AND
I THINK- BOTH- SENATORS HAVE
EXPRESSED A SOME OF MY CONCERNS
AND BUT I JUST WANT TO START BY
KNOWLEDGE GENE YOU KNOW SOME OF
THE WILDFIRES THAT WE'VE HAD IN
THE PAST YEARS AND YOU KNOW I
WAS PART OF MANY OF THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT. ARE YEP
NEGOTIATIONS WITH AB TEN FIFTY
FOUR I BELIEVE IT WAS AND YOU
KNOW WE HEARD THE STORIES OF
LIVES LOST WE HEARD THE STORIES
OF HOMES DESTROYED AND LET'S
FACE A SIMILAR TRAUMA THAT THESE
FAMILIES HAVE IT ENTERED I MEAN
SOMEONE NEVER GET OVER IT SO WE
HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE
IS A REAL CRISIS HERE AND WE-
ARE TRYING TO SOLVE THIS ISSUE.
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND I DO HAVE
SOME REAL CONCERNS ABOUT COST
AND THIS IS A VERY AMBITIOUS
PLAN WHICH IS YOU KNOW
ABSOLUTELY NEEDED AS WE'VE
ALREADY STATED SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED TO START MOVING FORWARD
TOWARDS BUT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
THE COST BEING PUSHED DOWN TO
RATE PAYERS AND- AND I DO
APPRECIATE THAT YOU KNOW THE
EXTENT PRECISION I HAD OVER THE
WEEKEND WITH AUTHOR IN FACT I
APPRECIATE THE- AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE SHARED WITH. MORNING ARE
BUT I STILL I BELIEVE THAT- EVEN
THOUGH THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
STATES THAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO
EXHAUST ALL FEDERAL. AND STATE
FUNDING BEFORE THEY CAN RECOVER
FROM RATE PAYERS I THINK THEY'RE
STILL GOING TO BE A COST ON THE
LASSEN AND WE ARE STRUGGLING IN
TERMS OF- I THINK ONE OF THE
SPEAKERS STATED THE INFLECTION
INFLICT THE INFORMATION THAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH RIGHT NOW AND
SO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT.
ARE THERE IS A LITTLE BIT YOU
KNOW MORE OFTEN IT'S AS IT
PERTAINS TO TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T TO PASS HIGH COST
TO OUR REPAIRS NUMBER ONE BUT I
TO I ALSO HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT I THE I USE YOU KNOW OUR
CAN DO THIS VOLUNTARILY BUT THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES ARE
BEING ASKED TO DO THIS IT'S VERY
COSTLY AS WELL AND SO AGAIN I
FEEL AT THE END. OUR REPAIRS MAY
LOSE EITHER WAY BUT IT'S
NECESSARY IT'S IMPORTANT- IT'LL
SAVE LIVES AND SO I'M. ALSO
TRYING TO ENCOURAGE THE AUTHORED
TO FIND THAT MY GROUND WITH THE
TELE. COMPANIES TO REALLY SIT
DOWN WITH EVERYONE AND AS
EVIDENCED BY ALL THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE BROUGHT THIS MORNING I
KNOW ALL THAT HE HAS COMMITTED-
YOU KNOW HE MADE THAT COMMITMENT
TO ME TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION SO I ALSO WANT TO
SEE IT MOVE FORWARD TO SEE WHAT
WE CAN. I GET TOOK A PLACE- IF
AT ALL POSSIBLE BUT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL WITH THE-
SOME QUESTIONS CONCERNS BUT I
WILL JUST LEAVE IT AT THAT TO
ENSURE THAT. WE CONTINUE TO.
FIND SOMETHING THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO SAVE LIVES AND- AND
MOVES TO THE NEXT YOU KNOW
FUTURE GENERATIONS. SO THANK YOU
FOR HEARING ME AND- I WILL TURN
IT OVER TO YOU. CENTER BRADFORD
. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I TO
RISE IN ONE EXPRESSED GREAT
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL AS FOR
THE ONLY MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE WHO WORK FOR UTILITY.
I WILL SHARE WITH YOU THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT UNDERGROUNDING HAS
BEEN IN EXISTENCE FOR MANY OF
THESE PLACES FOR ALMOST A
HUNDRED YEARS. AND IT WAS
TRANSISTORS AND- INDUCTORS THAT
WEREN'T MADE AS WELL AS THEIR
MADE TODAY AND WE DIDN'T HAVE
THESE ONGOING. FOREST FIRES IN
MY TWELVE YEARS AT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON THERE WAS ONLY
ONE MAJOR FIRE IN OUR SERVICE
TERRITORY IN IT WASN'T CALLS BY
THE UTILITIES INFRASTRUCTURE SO
IN ONE BREATH WE WANT TO BLAME
IT ON CLIMATE CHANGE BUT AT THE
SAME TIME WE NEED TO BLAME IT ON
THE FACT THAT WE DO NOT. MANAGE
TO FORCED ANYMOREWE DO NOT
CLEAR WINDS AND AS AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO REPRESENTED URBAN AREA I
UNDERSTOOD AND HEARD FROM MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE RURAL AREAS
WHEN WE WERE TRYING TO GET LINE
CLEARING DONE. THAT'S THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGE RIGHT NOW A
COBINATION OF FILLING THE CUT
DOWN TREES. AND OUR CLIMATE
CHANGE BECAUSE AGAIN MOST OF
THESE POLES AND WIRES HAVE BEEN
IN SOME OF THE SAME RIGHT AWAYS
FOR ALMOST A HUNDRED YEARS AND
WE WEREN'T HAVING ONGOING FIRES.
THIRTY FORTY FIFTY SIXTY SEVENTY
YEARS AGO IT IS RECENT
OCCURRENCE AS EVEN AUTHORS
STATED IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
HAPPENED SINCE ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND SET OUT SIXTEEN.
BECAUSE WE HAVE SEEN CLIMATE
CHANGE AND WE HAVE SEEN A LOCK A
MANAGING OF OUR FORCE AND THERE
WILL BE A REAL COSTS TO
RATEPAYERS. THE UNDERGROUND LINE
IS USUALLY ABOUT A MILLION
DOLLARS PLUS A MILE. AND THAT'S
BOUNCE ON THE REPAIRS BELIEVE
ME. IT'S NOT A CHEAP ENDEAVOR I
OVERSAW. THREE OR FOUR RULE
TWENTY PROJECTS THAT'S IN URBAN
AREAS DURING MY TIME AT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON AND DELAY IN
JUST BY DOING THAT ALONE IT
WON'T HAPPEN OVERNIGHT. THIS
WILL TAKE. YEARS TO GET THE
AVERAGE UPRIGHTS ARE PROJECT
PLANNED AND DONE AND THEN YOU
TALK ABOUT THE JOINT POLL
SITUATION WHERE YOU HAVE TELCO
AND CABLE AND ON NOW BROADBAND
ON THE ON THE POLE TO AND NOW
ASKING THEM TO GOING TO A TRENCH
I'M GONNA TELL YOU FOLKS.
UNDERGROUNDING SPECIALLY HIGH
TRANSMISSION LINES LEADS TO
LONGER OUTAGES SO WHAT WE WILL
CREATE AS A CUSTOMER BASE WHO
NOW WILL BE COMPLAINING WHY HAS
MY POWER NOW BEEN OFF FOR DAYS
IF NOT WEEKS AT A TIME BECAUSE
WHEN IT'S OVERHEAD YOU CAN
EASILY SPOT. A BAD TRENDS-
TRANSFORMERS BAD- CONDUCTOR ARE
BAD RESISTIR A BAD WIRE WHEN
IT'S UNDERGROUND YOU HAVE TO DIG
IN SEARCH FOR THAT BAD OUTAGE
AND IT TAKES SOMETIMES DAYS TO
FIND OUT SO I JUST WANT TO
CAUTION I UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT IS BUT I THINK.
WE'RE MOVING OUT IN THE WERE IN
THE WRONG DIRECTION IF WE THINK
UNDERGROUNDING IS GOING TO SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM WHAT WILL SOLVE IT.
FOR PENNIES ON THE DOLLAR IS
DOING BETTER MANAGING OF OUR
FORCE. APPLYING BLIND CLEARING
TO REMOVE THE FUEL THAT EXISTS
THERE TODAY SO I CAN'T SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE TODAY. VERY WELL
CENTER STERN. MAYBE THE AUTHOR
WILL WANT TO COMMENT ED I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR AND I HI
IBM BECAUSE THEY SHARE MY
COLLEAGUES FROM LA HE'S
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS NEW CLIMATE
CHANGE FACTOR IN TRANSMISSION
RISK- BUT BECAUSE OF THAT THAT
RISK- WITH HIGHER WINDS WITH
HOTTER DAYS. WITH MORE WILDFIRE
TO ME THAT. THAT THAT COUNSELS
US TO EXPEDITE A BILL LIKE THIS
TO BE MOVING IT FORWARD- AND
I'VE WHAT I SENSE FROM THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND FROM
THE AUTHOR AND I WANT TO GET.
THE AUTHORS COMMENTS ON THIS
BUT- SO WILLINGNESS TO. TO
TARGET THIS BILL TO LOOK AT
FIRESTONE SPECIFICALLY TO
REALLY. TAILOR THAT RISK. TO NOT
MAKE THIS AN OPEN ENDED
RATEPAYER COSTS BUT BUT
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO DEAL
SPECIFICALLY. WITH WILDFIRE RISK
AND THE AREAS THAT HAVE BEEN
GETTING THEIR POWER SHUT OFF.
YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR AND
WE'VE SEEN THESE WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PLANS COME OUT. AND
HIT THE POWER STILL GETS SHUT
DOWN EVERY TIME THE WIND KICKS
IN THE OVER SEVENTY MILES AN
HOUR SIXTY MILES AN HOUR SOME
DAYS NOT EVEN THAT. THE NEW OF
ELDERLY PEOPLE PEOPLE WHO DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO. THE MEDICAL
SERVICES PEOPLE ON NEBULIZERS
LITERALLY LOSING THEIR POWER
LOSING THEIR LIFELINE- I THINK
WE GET. ON THE OVERHEAD SYSTEM
BUT I WOULD I WOULD REALLY HOPE
FROM THE AUTHOR IS THAT. THROUGH
ALL THE PRESSURE YOU'RE GETTING.
AND ALL THOSE STAKEHOLDER
MANAGEMENT YOU HAVE TO DO THAT
YOU DON'T- WE DON'T JUST FOCUS
ON THE P. JEANNIE CHALLENGE
BECAUSE I THINK IN EDISON
COUNTRY- WE'VE BEEN HAVING SOME
OF. VERY SIMILAR CHALLENGES WE
LIKE TO SEE SOME SIMILAR
LEADERSHIP FROM MEDICINES. CO IN
FROM FROM CORPORATE SIDE THAT
WE'VE SEEN FROM P. JEANNIE IN
TERMS OF THEIR COMMITMENT FOR.
FOR MILES OF LINES WE HAVEN'T
SEEN THAT YET. BUT I WOULD LOVE
TO BE ADDED ON AS A CO AUTHOR
FRANKLY ENJOYING USES SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN THIS EFFORT. I
APPRECIATE AND TRUST YOU TO
NAVIGATE THE ALL THE COMPLEX
ISSUES BUT LET'S BE CLEAR THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY HAS
A STAKE IN THIS TOO. AND THEY.
ARE BENEFITING FROM THE USE
THOSE LINES. A SO TO LEAVE THEM
OUT OF THE PUZZLE AND CUT THEM
OUT ENTIRELY AND SAVE THE
TELECOM INDUSTRY. SHOULDN'T BE
PAYING PART OF THIS. BELIES THE
NATURE OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
ITSELF THAT EQUIPMENT HANGING ON
THOSE LINES WE'VE ALL GOT TO DO
OUR PART. SO I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING EVERYONE TOGETHER AND-
THAT. WOULD MOVE THE BILL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AND IF YOU HAVE
A COMMENT ON. ON JUST THAT YOUR
YOUR- YOUR EFFORTS AROUND THE
REFINEMENT IN SOME OF THE ISSUES
MAY BE RAISED BY MY COLLEAGUE AS
WELL AS MYSELF. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. A VERY WELL ANYONE ELSE.
AND YEAH WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR STERN TO- THE BILL
FORWARD- WITH AMENDMENTS. A AND
THE AMENDMENT WOULD BE- YOU HAS
TO BE AMENDED IN GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE CENTERS FOR DID YOU WANT
MAKES COMMENTS I WOULD CHOICE
RIGHT POLITICIANS. I THE ROOM
FOR A FEW MINUTES BUT YEAH I
WOULD BECAUSE- WHAT YOU KNOW
EARLY STAGES BILL AND OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF
DISCUSSIONS WITH SHERMAN. BUT
WHAT I WANT TO SAY IS THAT.
TWENTY FOUR POINT TWO MILLION
CARS ON THE ROAD THAT'S HOW MUCH
THE POLLUTION SMOG THAT FOR THE
SMOKE ALL THE STAFF WERE ENGAGED
IN A DEEP DISCUSSION. ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE AND WHAT TO DO
AND SO ON THE ONE HAND WORKING
ON ELECTRIFICATION WORKING ON.
ALL OF THESE STANDARDS TO TRY TO
REDUCE THE ATMOSPHERIC
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE. AND THE
OTHER HAND THESE FIRES JOSH TO
BY ORDERS OF MAGNITUDE- CHANGE
EVERYTHING. AND SO I JUST WANTED
TO- GIVE CREDIT TO THE AUTHOR
WHO IS IT OFFERS ME AYE I GO
INTO A HUNDRED BILLION DOLLAR
BOND ISSUE IF WE COULD. JUST
UNDERGROUND EVERYTHING AS
QUICKLY AS WE POSSIBLY CAN TO
REDUCE THIS RISK AGAIN WHEN I'M
TRYING TO BRING TO THIS
DISCUSSION IS A LARGER CONTEXT
MISTER CHAIRMAN. IN TERMS OF THE
LARGER DYNAMIC OF WHAT WE'RE
FACING I CERTAINLY DON'T YOU
KNOW. AT THE SAME CHALLENGES THE
COMMUNITIES I REPRESENT THAT
CENTER MCGUIRE DOES BUT THE
CHALLENGES HE FACED AFFECTS ALL
OF US IN CALIFORNIA. AND I JUST
THINK THAT AS WE ENGAGE IN THIS
DISCUSSION. YEAH THERE'S A LOT
OF DETAILS AND YES DIFFICULT.
BUT WE GOT TO THINK MUCH BIGGER
AND I GIVE GREAT CREDIT TO THE
AUTHOR FOR THINKING BIG IN THIS
AND- ONE SUPPORT THE BILL. VERY
WELL WE HAVE A MOTION- DID YOU
WANT TO MAKE CLOSING COMMENTS
AND REQUIRE YES I WOULD THINK
YOU SO MUCH RESEARCH CARE AND
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION HERE
TODAY. A FEW ITEMS AND JUST BEEN
TAKING NOTES AND I'M GRATEFUL.
RIGHT NOW P. GENIES BEEN IN
ABOUT ONE POINT THREE TO ONE
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR AND TREE TRIMMING. ONE
POINT THREE ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION. SO THAT'S GOING TO GO
ON A PER TUTTI IF WE DON'T DO
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD HAVE
DONE YEARS AGO AND THAT START ON
THE GROUND IN THE LINES. SO THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE SERVICE
TOWARD THE TERRITORY'S ESTY
GENIE SOCAL EDISON PG&E THEIR
BASS. BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS SIX
. I'M A BIG BELIEVER LOOKING
FORWARD BUT TO BE ABLE TO LOOK
FORWARD TO GOING TO LEARN FROM
THE PAST WHAT WE LEARNED ABOUT
P. JEANNIE. THEY HAVE VASTLY
UNDER INVESTED IN HARDENING
THEIR LINES. THEY HAVE UNDER
INVESTED IN. FOR ME TREE
TRIMMING AROUND THE LINES
THEY'VE UNDER INVESTED IN FIRE
SAFETY NAMES UNDER INVESTED IN
UNDERGROUND. IT'S A NEW DAY. SO
HERE'S WHAT I WOULD SAY.
LITERALLY THE C. E. O. IS SAYING
THAT SHE WANTS TO UNDERGROUND
TEN THOUSAND MILES OF LINE.
THERE'S NO PLAN. WE NEED TO
DEVELOP THE PLAN TO GET THE JOB
DONE. 99% REMEMBER THE NUMBER
99% 99% OF ALL FOREST FIRES.
THEY DON'T START WINNING
UNDERGROUND 99% IN WHEN WE TAKE
A LOOK AT WITH THE ADDED USE THE
OUTAGES. FULL IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA ARE LEGALLY GOING
WEEKS WITHOUT POWER YOU ALL
WEEKS. WE DON'T LIVE IN THE
NATION IT DOESN'T HAVE POWER FOR
WEEKS. AND HOW LONG ARE WE GOING
TO TOLERATE THIS. WE'RE THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WITHOUT
POWER FOR WEEKS. THIS IS INSANE
. AND WE'RE ONE OF THE FAILURES
AND JUST BEING REALLY CANDID
I'LL GIVE YOU MY BELIEF IN MY
SEVEN YEARS IN THIS LEGISLATORS
NOT HOLDING THIS UTILITY
ACCOUNTABLE TO BE ABLE TO FIX
OUR LINE AND MAKE THE
COMMUNITIES MORE FIRE SAFE. SO
LOOK NO BILL IS PERFECT. NO I
DON'T FALL IN LOVE WITH THE
BILLS THAT I HAVE BUT AT THE
SAME TIME THOUGH MY GOD HOW MANY
YEARS IS IT GOING TO TAKE FOR US
TO GET. THIS DONE. SO I WANT TO
REMIND FOLKS ABOUT THIS BILL
IT'S OFTEN. IT'S OFTEN. THE VAST
MAJORITY COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE
TODAY VOTED FOR SB TEN FIFTY
FOUR WHICH WAS OFTEN. SO WE'RE
NOT SO AS THE GENIE IN SOCAL
EDISON IF THEY DON'T WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN IT THEY DON'T
HAVE TO PARTICIPATE. I GET IT
THEY DON'T LIKE HAVING
CHALLENGES WITH GREATER RETURN
BUT MY GOD HOW ELSE ARE WE GOING
TO HOLD UTILITIES ACCOUNTABLE TO
BE ABLE TO GET THE JOB DONE. AND
I ALSO SAID IN MY STATEMENT NOT
ALL UTILITIES ARE CREATED EQUAL
ESTY GENIE OVER HALF THEIR
SYSTEM IS UNDERGROUND OVER HALF
. WE SHOULD CELEBRATE THAT BUT
P. GENIES DOING LESS THAN A
HUNDRED MILES A YEAR TRY TO WRAP
UP NUMBERS REQUIRED SO WE HAVE
QUITE OF THE JOE KAY I'M JUST
GOING TO ENTER RIGHT HERE. ON
BROADBAND I WOULD WELCOME. THOSE
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES TO
SHOW US. WHERE THEY'RE CONCERNED
THAT THEY'RE NOT COMMITTED TO
PLAY BROADBAND BECAUSE I
GUARANTEE YOU IN THESE TEN
THOUSAND MILES OF HIGH FIRE RISK
LINES. THERE'S BARELY ANYTHING
THAT THEY'VE DONE THESE INCOMING
UTILITIES IN RURAL CALIFORNIA TO
BE ABLE TO DELIVER HIGH SPEED
INTERNET. SO CANDIDLY IT'S A BIT
DISINGENUOUS. AND IT'S A FALSE
ARGUMENT BUT I'M HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TO WORK IN HIS YOU
KNOW. TAKE ON BIG STUFF. YOU
WORK THROUGH THE ISSUES NOT ALL
BILLS A PERFECT BUT I COMMITTEE
EACH AND ONE EVERYONE OF YOU
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO WORK
THROUGH THIS WE'RE TO WORK
COLLABORATIVE LEE. I'M GRATEFUL
AND I WOULD BE REALLY HONORED
FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY BECAUSE
WE HAVE TO SAVE LIVES WE HAVE TO
END. THESE FIRES RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN ITEM. OKAY VERY GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE NOW WE
HAVE A MOTION CLERK PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SB EIGHT FOUR BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO BE AMENDED IN GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE WESSEL. HI WESSEL HI
DOLLY. BAKER BAKER BY BURGESS
BRADFORD. DODD DODD HI EGGMAN.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HI GROW
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE MIN. MAN I RUBIO.
RUBIO HI STERN. STERN HI. NINE A
STIR OKAY THAT HAS ENOUGH VOTES
TO GET OUT WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE
OF THE FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT BILL-
WE HAVE- S. B. TEN THIRTY TWO BY
SENATOR. BECKER A BILL RELATING
TO CLEAN ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE.
WELCOME CENTER. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS. AS YOU ALL
KNOW WE ARE ALL CONCERNED ABOUT
RISING ELECTRICITY RATES AT THE
SAME TIME WE NEED TO BE
INVESTING IN OUR SYSTEM TO
REDUCE WILDFIRE RISK AS WE
DISCUSSED AND WHICH ARE CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS. SB TEN THIRTY TWO
IS AN EFFORT TO MAKE BUILDING
ELECTRIC. BUILDING ELECTRICAL
TRANSMISSION FASTER AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY CHEAPER. THAT WE CAN
MINIMIZE THE IMPACT OF THIS
INVESTMENT ON OUR ENERGY BILLS.
ACACIA RECENTLY AT RECENT TWENTY
YEAR OUTLOOK FOR TRANSMISSION
PLANNING ESTIMATED THAT MORE
THAN THIRTY BILLION FOR THE
THIRTY FIVE BILLION IN NEW
TRANSMISSION CAPACITY. WILL BE
NEEDED BY TWENTY FORTY. WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO IF WE ARE GOING
TO HAVE TO BUILD OUT THAT MUCH
TRANSMISSION. THE BETTER TAKES
STEPS TO DO AS EFFICIENTLY AND
COST EFFECTIVELY AS POSSIBLE.
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE PRIORITY
SB ONE HUNDRED ACTIONS REPORT
CONSIDERED AFFORDABILITY
CONCERNS. IN IDENTIFIED THE
FORMATION OF A TRANSMISSION
AUTHORITY. SECOND FUND AND BUILD
NEW TRANSMISSION PROJECTS. AS
WOULD REDUCE THE COST REPAIRS
AND BUILDING OUT TRANSMISSION.
SB TEN THIRTY TWO IS AN EFFORT
TO IMPLEMENT THAT
RECOMMENDATION. WE MODEL THE
PROPOSED INFRASTRUCTURE THIRTY
ON A SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION
THIRTY NEW MEXICO WHICH ALREADY
WORKED IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
PRIVATE SECTOR TO GET TWO MAJOR
NEW TRANSMISSION LINES BUILT.
BASIC EXPERIENCE WE KNOW THATLOWERING COSTS IS ABOUT MORE
THAN JUST FINANCING. IN ADDITION
TO BUILDING TO LEVERAGE LOW COST
STATE FINANCING IN
INFRASTRUCTURE THIRTY. HAS OF A
SET OF TOOLS THAT CAN HELP
REDUCE PROJECT RISKS AND
TIMELINES. BY REDUCING
DUPLICATIVE REVIEW PROCESS SEES
AND EXPEDITING PERMITTING AND
SITING. THAT'S WHY WE
INFRASTRUCTURE THIRTY THE
COMPARTMENT UTILITIES OR OTHER
TRANSMISSION DEVELOPERS AND HAVE
AN OWNERSHIP STAKE IN THESE
PROJECTS. THE NUMBER OF GROUPS
HAVE RAISED CONCERNS ABOUT THE
STRUCTURE OF INFRASTRUCTURE
THIRTY IS CURRENTLY PROPOSED IN
A VERY KNOWLEDGE THAT ITIS A
WORK IN PROGRESS AND IT'S A BIG
IT'S A BIG TOPIC. INTERESES
BILLS WAY TO GET PEOPLE TALKING
ABOUT HOW WE WERE GOING TO GET A
LOT OF TRANSITION BUILT. IN A
RELATIVELY SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME
WELL PROTECTING RATEPAYERS FROM
ESCALATING ENERGY COSTS. I
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE RAISED QUESTION
WHETHER THIS IS THE BEST
APPROACH FOR KEEPING THOSE
GOALS. AND PUTTING OUT IMPORTANT
CONCERNS ABOUT LIABILITY.
DELAYED THESE CONCERNS- AND
TALKING TO THE CHAIR OF OPPOSING
A CHANGE THIS BILL. AT THE FIRST
OPPORTUNITY. TO ONE WHICH WILL
DIRECT THE RELEVANT AGENCIES TO
STUDY THE QUESTION. OF WHETHER
AND HOW PUBLIC FINANCING OF
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE. CAN GET THIS
CRUCIAL WORK DONE FASTER AND
CHEAPER. AND TO RETURN THE
LEGISLATURE PROPOSAL ABOUT HOW
WE MOVE FORWARD. WITH A PROPOSED
CHANGE ESPECIALLY ASKED FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. IMAGE OF ONE WITNESS
ON THE LINE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND- I JUST WANTED TO- ASK YOU A
CENTER IF YOUR- SPEAKERS. ARE
AWARE OF YOUR PROPOSAL. YES ROOM
WHAT WITH THIS AND I BELIEVE SO
OKAY- SO WE WILL NOW GO TO
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE YOU HAVE- ONE ONE
SPEAKER ALEX- BRICKELL. AND HE'S
WITH THE CLEANER TASK FORCE AND
WILL- IS HE HERE PRESENT OR IS
ON THE LINE. ON THE LINE OKAY
THEN YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES
MISSED RECALL PLEASE PROCEED. I
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON SHERMAN
WAY PHONE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THAT'S THE FIGHT
TODAY. I'M ALEX MICHAEL DIRECTOR
OF CLEAN ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE
DEPLOYMENT OF THE CLEAN AIR TASK
FORCE WE'RE A GLOBAL NGO WORKING
TO REDUCE AIR POLLUTION AND
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION QUICKLY
AFFORDABLY AND EQUITABLY. I WANT
TO START BY ECHOING COMMENTS
MADE EARLIER BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG AT THE COMMITTEE
HEARING- AND ECHOED AGAIN BY
SENATOR RECORD THE NEW
TRANSMISSION CAPACITY IS THE
LINCHPIN OF A RESILIENT. ECONOMY
AND THE STATE MUST URGENTLY
TACKLE CAR THEN PUT IT IN
CHALLENGES TO ACHIEVING.
EQUALITY AMBITION. I NOW TO
CONDUCT THE RIGHT STATE AID AND
OTHER READ OR TO. THAT WE FIND
THAT A AT THE ONE. LARA
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF NEW QUEEN
IN AND PUSH. THE TRADE
COMMISSION. PARTICULAR WILL
LIKELY NEED TO DOUBLE IN PRICE
TO ACCOMMODATE NEW USED IN THE
PLAYING ELECTRICITY
INTERCONNECTORS FIRST RENEWABLE
ENERGY RESOURCES. HOWEVER IT'S
BECOMING HARDER AND MORE
EXPENSIVE THE BILL MAJOR NEW
TRANSMISSION FACILITIESAND
STATE ALREADY FACING AN ENERGY
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS. THANK YOU
PROPER LOAN THE BALLOON ONE
HUNDRED AND 50% OVER THE LAST
DECADE. IT AND IT CAN TAKE TEN
YEARS OR MORE TO DEVELOP MAJOR
TRANSMISSION LINES. AND EVEN
TODAY IMPLICATION TRANSMISSION
CAPACITY IS BILLING THE CLIENT
AFFORDABILITY AND CLEAN AIR
BENEFITS. OF DOZENS OF LARGE
SALUTE FULLER PROJECT IN THE
STATE BANK CONTRIBUTED TO
CONTINUE USE OF POLLUTING FOSSIL. FUEL FACILITIES AND COMMUNITY
. I RECOGNIZE THESE CHALLENGES-
AND- COMMITTEE BACK ALREADY
MENTIONED THE JOINT AGENCIES
REPORT TO THE GOVERNOR ON
PRIORITY ISSUE ONE HUNDRED
ACTION. RECOMMENDS CREATING- AND
THE FORTY THE FACILITATION
MISSION DEVELOPMENT ANY. FOR
STRONGLY BELIEVES THAT THAT THE
AUTHORITY IS A REALLY GREAT
MODEL REDUCING COST TIME AND
COMPLEXITY. HOW CAN MISSION AND
STATE. WHILE INTEGRATING RATHER
THAN DUPLICATING IF THEY THINK
THAT THE TRANSMISSION PLANNING
PROCESS. WE ENVISION THE
AUTHORITY SUPPORTING THE MOST
CRITICAL YET CHALLENGING
TRANSMISSION NEED FROM THE BAY
RATHER THAN EVERY TRANSMISSION
LINE IN THE STATE EXAMPLES
INCLUDE INTEGRATING OFFER A WIND
TURBINE FOR STRENGTHENING TIES
BETWEEN THE NORTH AND SOUTH. AND
GIVEN THE DECADE LONG
DEVELOPMENT TIMELINE AND GROWING
COST FOR MAJOR TRANSMISSION
PROJECT. THE STATEMENT URGENTLY
IDENTIFY POLLUTION RECORD LOW
COUGH SUFFICIENT BALABAC OF
THESE CRITICAL TRANSMISSION
AFTER. SEVERAL TOOLS THAT WE
THINK MIGHT BE USEFUL ULTIMATELY
FOR THE FORTY ODD THE HOBBIT SHE
WHEN THE POLLS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
MENTIONED I'LL JUST REITERATE
PROVIDING LOW COST FINANCING THE
REVENUE BONDS OR OTHER
MECHANISMS AVOIDING REDUNDANT
PERMITTING REQUIREMENTS OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LEAD AGENCY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OF OKAY NOW
WILL- MOVED TO SPEAKERS. IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN THIRTY TO FEEL
JUST STATE. YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION ON MENTOR
ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY. OKAY
I WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
MODERATORS GET MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF
SB TEN THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN THIRTY TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
TEN THIRTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
MY FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE JACKPOT FOR
THREE FIFTY TOTAL VALIANT STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANKYOU
FOR YOUR BAKER. NINE FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GREAT PRODUCT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY STORAGE
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
THIRTY TWO. NINE EIGHTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
TURN THE UTILITY REFORM NETWORK
IN STRONG SUPPORT. NINE TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CHAU COLONIAL WITH THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY. REALITY
PROJECTS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
LINES IN Q. FOUR SB TEN THIRTY
TO SUPPORT. OKAY NUMBER OF
SPEAKERS ARE WILL GO TO-
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION I'M GONNA
ASK THE SPEAKERS TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THE PROPOSED
AMENDED BILL THAT. COURSE NOT
THE STRUCTURE WHAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING TODAY BUT WHAT THE
AUTHOR AS INTENDED TO DO. THAT
SO IF YOU ARE FAMILIAR WITH
THAT- I ASKED YOU TO SPEAK TO
THAT. AND YOU HAVE WE WILL BEGIN
WITH- JOHNSON BUT NEED JONES
WITH INDEPENDENT ENERGY
PRODUCERS ASSOCIATION YOU HAVE A
MINUTE AND A HALF. YES YES-
MISTER CHAIRMAN JETS MANY JOBS
INDEPENDENT ENERGY PRODUCERS AND
WE ARE NOT QUITE SURE WHAT WE
HEARD- THE AUTHOR- COMMIT TO-
THE REALITY IS FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE WE REPRESENT PEOPLE
WHO ARE TRYING TO DELIVER. CLEAN
RESOURCES TO CALIFORNIA AND
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA SO WE'RE
VERY SYMPATHETIC WITH THAT ISSUE
HOWEVER WE THINK THE LAST THING
IN THE WORLD WE NEED RIGHT NOW-
IS YET ANOTHER STATE AGENCY
DEALING WITH- CLEAN ENERGY AND
THE TRANSMISSION SYSTEM- SO- WE
WE'VE HEARD SOME VERY GOOD
IDEAS- WE THINK THAT- PERHAPS-
YOU KNOW FINANCE. YOU KNOW
FINANCING THROUGH EXISTING
BINDING AUTHORITIES IN THE STATE
ABOUT THE NEVER STRUCTURE BACK
THAT MAY BE A GOOD IDEA- GIVING
THE EYES SO THE PRESUMPTION- A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION THAT WHEN
THEY IDENTIFY SOMETHING IS
NEEDED IT'S NEEDED YOU DON'T
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THAT AGAIN.
THAT'S A GOOD IDEA- AND- YOU
KNOW THE IT IT MAY WELL BE THAT
WE NEED TO DO SOME ADDITIONAL
SEQUEL- SIMPLIFICATIONS ARE ALL
GREAT IDEAS. NONE OF THEM
REQUIRE CREATING YET ANOTHER
AGENCY TO DEAL WITH THIS YEAH
AND DO WE AT ONE TIME WE HAD THE
CALIFORNIA POWER AUTHORITY- IT
WENT NOWHERE WE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME AND RESOURCES. CREATING IT
NO PROJECT CAME OUT OF IT SO I
WOULD REALLY- WE DO WE DO NOT
HAVE THE TIME OR THE ENERGY RATE
NOW TO DIVERT RESOURCES TO
CREATE YET ANOTHER AUTHORITY
THAT WE DON'T BELIEVE. IS
ACTUALLY THAT THE RIGHT ANSWER
TO GETTING THIS. TRANSMISSION
AND TIMELY MATTER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND JUST CLARIFY. THE
AUTHOR DID AND YET AND- CENTER
BAKER YOU MIGHT WANT TO ADD TO
MY COMMENTS BUT- THE AYE THE
IDEA IS AT THE CENTER WORKING
WITH COMMITTEE IS GOING TO COME
UP WITH A BILL THAT ALL ANALYZE
HOW TO ACT EXPEDITE
TRANSMISSION. HOW TO IDENTIFY IT
WHERE IT'S NEEDED AND HOW TO GO
ABOUT- DOING THAT IN A IN A MORE
EFFICIENT. MANNER MORE COST
EFFECTIVE MANNER AND SO THE IDEA
IS TO- TO ANALYSIS AND THAT HAVE
A STUDY COME BACK WITH SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS THE LEGISLATURE
NOT ACCOMPLISH THAT. SO IT'S NOT
IT DOESN'T EXCLUDE. THE CREATION
OF AN AGENCY BUT IT IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY DICTATE THAT THAT BE
THE ONLY WAY TO ACHIEVE THAT
AGAIN IF- IF WE GO DOWN THIS
PATH AND ASK FOR A VERY-
THOROUGH ANALYSIS OF HOW THIS IS
DONE WE WOULD LIKE EVERYTHING TO
BE ON THE TABLE. THAT WE GET
ANOTHER ANALYSIS IT GETS TO THE
CRUX OF HOW DO WE ACCOMPLISH
THIS STATE SCHOOLS OF. OF
CREATING THIS INFRASTRUCTURE AT
THE MOST FISHING COSTS AND MOST
EFFICIENTLY EFFECTIVELY- AND
BASICALLY WHAT WHAT WHAT THE
STRATEGY IS TO DO THAT OR WHAT
THE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE GIVEN-
CALIFORNIA'S UNIQUE- REGULATORY.
FRAMEWORK FOR ENERGY AND POWER
SO- CENTER BAKER DID YOU WANNA
ADD TO THAT. IF YOU WANT TO
CLARIFY AND BECAUSE OF WAS NOT
THE PACKAGE JUST TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE CLEAR. AFTER TALKING
CHAIR WE DECIDE MAKE THIS A
STUDY BILL- ON THE ISSUES. YOU
MENTION ALSO BEGINS FOR
SPECIFICALLY RUN HEALTH HOW
PUBLIC FINANCING A PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE. CAN HELP GET THIS
WORK DONE. FASTER AND- MORE
CHEAPLY BUT SHRIMP MAKE SURE MY-
COLLEAGUES IN THE IN THE ROOM
ARE CLEAR ON THAT. THAT AFTER
TALKING SURE WE'RE GONNA MAKE
THE CITY A STUDY BILL OKAY VERY
GOOD SO WE'LL GO TO THE NEXT-
LEAD OPPOSITION SPEAKER JOHN
KENNEDY WITH THE- ROLE COUNTY
WERE SET REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA- MISTER KENNEDY AGAIN
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO THE
PROPOSAL. GOOD AFTERNOON KENNEDY
WITH RC RC AND ALTERNATIVE IN MY
COMMENTS TO WHAT WAS SUGGESTED.
STILL TRYING TO WORK MY WAY
THROUGH IT AND SEE- HOW THIS
COULD END UP. I THINK WE ARE
GENERALLY ALIGNED WITH WHAT THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT IS TO DRIVE DOWN
COSTS AND TO EXPEDITE THESE
PROJECTS. WE'VE HAD PROBLEMS
WITH ENERGY AFFORDABILITY IN A
LOT OF OUR RURAL COMMUNITIES AND
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF PROBLEMS
WITH- WITH DELAYS AND
RELIABILITY SO WE'RE VERY
INTERESTED IN GETTING TO THE
CORE PROBLEM HERE AND FINDING
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS TO GET THERE.
BUT I THINK EVEN WITH THE A
STUDY WE WOULD STILL HAVE MAJOR
CONCERNS OF THE MODEL INVOLVES
THE STATE AS AN AUTHORITY WHO'S
DOING THESE THINGS- AND OUR
CONCERNS ARE BECAUSE THE
DOWNSTREAM IMPLICATIONS ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. FIRST IF THE STATE
IS INVOLVED IS THE AUTHORITY
OWNING THESE FACILITIES- THOSE
ARE EXEMPT FROM LOCAL ZONING
LAWS AND THAT WOULD EXEMPT THEM
FROM LOCAL AUTHORITY TO COME IN
AND DETERMINE WHETHER THOSE
PLANS WITH THOSE FACILITIES. ARE
CONSISTENT WITH LOCAL PRIORITIES
AND OBJECTIVES SECOND IF THE
STATE IS INVOLVED IN OWNERSHIP
IT WOULD- INVOLVED IN A HIT TO
LOCAL PROPERTY TAX REVENUES.
WHICH IS THE LIFEBLOOD OF THE
PROVISION OF LOCAL EMERGENCY
SERVICES SO AGAIN IF THE STATE
IS THE ONE WHO IS RUNNING THIS
OWNING THE LAND. THEN WE HAVE
SOME REAL CONCERNS WITH THE
DOWNSTREAM IMPLICATIONS. UNLESS
THEIR PROPERTY TAX BACKFILL AND
LAST THOSE PROJECTS ARE SUBJECT
LOCAL ZONING AS WELL. AND THEN
FINALLY APPRECIATE WHAT THE
AUTHOR SUGGESTED ABOUT
LIABILITY- I DON'T THINK ANYONE
WANTS THE STATE TO TAKE ON
GREATER LIABILITY AND SO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING THROUGH THOSE
ISSUES AS WELL- WOULD LOVE TO
SEE THE LANGUAGE THAT COMES OUT
AND- RECONSIDER POSITION
ACCORDINGLY BUT- I THINK IF IT.
INVOLVES THE STATE AND- THE
SIMILAR CAPACITY HERE YOUR RUNS
NOW BUT IT WOULD HAVE GOT YOUR-
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'LL GO TO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION- THE FROM THE- PLAY
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO YOUR
NAME. FILIATION YOUR POSITION ON
THE MATTER. THANK YOU NICOLINO
THIS WITH NY OF GAS AND
ELECTRIC I IN A POSITION TO THE
BILL PRINT LOOK FOR SENIOR
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON VALERIE TRIAL OF LAJOS
PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC COMPANY
OPPOSED TO THE BILL AND FRIENDS.
AND LOOK FORCING THOSE MOMENTS
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- ANYONE ELSE HERE IN
THE GALLERY OKAY WE'LL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES NOW MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TEN THIRTY TWO
. PLEASE LIMIT YOUR COMMENT
SECTION AND. NAME AFFILIATION A
POSITION MEASURE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TEN THIRTY
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB TEN THIRTY TWO. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. NINE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND YOU COULD
START SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL IN
PRINT AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
TESTING AND THEN. THANK YOU.
FINE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE SHOULD
CREATE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALCHAMBER IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL AND PRINT AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR THANK
YOU. WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TEN THIRTY
TWO. OKAY VERY WELL WE'LL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE DO WE HAVE
AND THE DEBATE HERE WITH THE
MEMBERS COMMENTS THE MOTION.
CENTER GONZALEZ- JUST MOVE THE
BILL AT ONE OKAY WE HAVE A
MOTION. TO MOVE UP I GUESS THE
MEN THE- AND MAYBE ALASKA. BY
THE AMENDMENT WOULD BE TO- A
PASS- THE BILL TO GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE WHERE IT WOULD BE
AMENDED. THE CORRECT OKAY VERY
WELL- CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. SB TEN THIRTY TWO BY FOR THE
RECORD THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
BE AMENDED IN GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE WESSEL HI WESSEL HI
DOLLY. BAKER BAKER HI FORGES
PORGES KNOWN BRADFORD. DODD.
EGGMAN GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I GROWN
HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG AYE
MCGUIRE. MAN MAN HI RUBIO. RUBIO
HI STERN. SIX AS CHAIR WITH ONE
OKAY WILL KEEP THE ROLE OF THE
PROPS OF MEMBERS. WE'LL GO ON TO
ITEM SEVEN SB FOURTEEN SIXTY
NINE CENTER BUT BRADFORD. OF THE
RELATED TO DEMAND ELASTICITY.
THAT IS OUR FOR UNDERWEAR WHAT
IS THIS YEAH. BANKS ALL OF THEM. THANK YOU MR S. B. FOUR SIX
ONE FOUR SIX NINE- WILL
AUTHORIZE THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION TO UTILIZE
A RULE RATEMAKING PROCESS
REFERRED TO AS THE COUPLING TO
PROMOTE WATER CONSERVATION THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS RECOMMENDS
REMEMBER THAT I WILL BE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO TAKE TODAY HOWEVER
I WANT TO ASK FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON LANGUAGE TO OBTAIN MORE
CERTAINTY THAT TO PC WILL
ACTUALLY CONSIDER DECOUPLING
ENTIRE LANGUAGE AROUND THE OVER
COLLECTION AND- UNDER COLLECTION
THE RATES CALIFORNIA'S CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING SEVERE DROUGHT
CONDITIONS. AND DUE TO CLIMATE
CHANGE IT'S GETTING WORSE
ACCORDING TO RESEARCHERS AT THE
LAWRENCE BERKELEY NATIONAL
LABORATORY BY THE YEARS- THE
TWENTY FORTIES SYRUP NO PACKED
COULD ALL BUT DISAPPEAR AND
CURRENTLY THE SIERRA SNOWPACK
SUPPLIES ABOUT 30% A
CALIFORNIA'S WATER CENTER
BACKGROUND ARE PROUD TO AUTHORED
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN SIXTY NINE
BECAUSE IT VANCE'S WATER
CONSERVATION BY AUTHORIZING THE-
UC TO IMPLEMENT. FOR DECADES OF
SUCCESS IN ENERGY- UTILITIES
HAVE- DONE WITH THE COUPLING SB
FOURTEEN SIXTY NINE ALLOWS WATER
SUPPLIERS TO IMPLEMENT EQUITABLE
RATE STRUCTURES FOR THOSE WHO
USE MORE PAY MORE. IT ENABLES
WATER SUPPLIERS TO MAINTAIN
ROBUST SAVE OUR WATER
CONSERVATION PROGRAMS AND
ELIMINATE. INCENTIVES TO PROFIT
BY SELLING MORE WATER. THE
COUPLING SEVERS THE LINK BETWEEN
THE AMOUNT OF WATER THAT
CUSTOMERS CHOOSE AND UTILITIES
FINANCE INSTEAD OF REALIZING
WINDFALL PROFITS WHEN CUSTOMERS
USE MORE WATER UTILITIES ONLY
RECOVER THE COSTS THE COMMISSION
DETERMINES IS NEEDED TO OPERATE
THEIR SYSTEMS IN SHORT THE
COUPLING BREAKS THE DICTION. OF
THE OUT TO WATER SEALS. FRENE
UTILITY SUPPORTERS ON PROMOTING
ROBUST WATER CONSERVATION OUT
EFFORTS. ALL ONE RECENT PEER
REVIEW STUDIES SHOW THAT THANKS
TO COUPLING THE WATER SUPPLIERS
REGULATED BY THE P. C. WERE
TWICE AS LIKELY TO MEET THEIR
CONSERVATION GOALS AND THAT
CONSUMERS SAVE CONSIDERABLY MORE
WATER THAN THOSE WITHOUT TWO
COPLINK TODAY TO TESTIFY AS RAMI
COLIN. A DIRECTOR REGULATORY
AFFAIRS CALIFORNIA WATER
SERVICES AND A FORMER DIRECTOR
OF THE PC WATER DIVISION AND
EVAN JACOBS DIRECTOR OF EXTERNAL
AFFAIRS AT CALIFORNIA WILL
AMERICAN WATER I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. OKAY VERY
WELL WE'LL GO- YOU HAVE- SPEAKER
IN SUPPORT OF TWO SPEAKERS-
ORGANIZED PRESENTATION BEGINNING
WITH RAMI KAHLON AND- WILL GIVE
A MINUTE AND A HALF IF HE'S ON
THE PHONE THREE IF HE'S READY.
PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS RANI KEY
LOCK I CURRENTLY SERVE AS
DIRECTOR OF REGULATORY AFFAIRS
FOR CALIFORNIA WATER SERVICE
PREVIOUSLY I SERVED AS DIRECTOR.
OF WATER DIVISION AT THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION FOR TWELVE
YEARS THE RATIONALE FOR SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN SIXTY NINE BOILS
DOWN TO TWO FACTORS WATER
CONSERVATION AND AFFORDABILITY.
CONSERVATION IS NO LONGER
SOMETHING THAT WE PRACTICE
DURING DROPS WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
IT MEANS IT'S NOW A DAILY IMPAIR
IT. SB FOURTEEN SIXTY NINE
ADVANCES THAT GOAL BY ENABLING
WATER UTILITIES COULD TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF INDUSTRY BEST
PRACTICE KNOWN AS DECOUPLING.
THE COMPANY HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN HELPING YOU SEE
REGULATED UTILITIES ACHIEVE
WATER CONSERVATION AFTER THE
LAST DROP A PEER REVIEWED STUDY
FOUND THAT THE P. C. REGULATED
UTILITIES NOT ONLY SAVE
CONSIDERABLY MORE WATER THAN.
THEIR PUBLIC AGENCY COUNTERPARTS
BUT ALSO WERE TWICE AS LIKELY TO
MEET CONSERVATION STANDARDS SET
BY GOVERNOR BROWN SB FOURTEEN
SIXTY NINE ALSO ADVANCES THE
STATE'S GOAL TO ENSURE WATER
AFFORDABILITY. RECENT RATE
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT
CUSTOMERS OF UTILITIES WITH THE
COUPLE HAVE WATER BILLS THAT ARE
UP 227% LOWER THAN THEY
OTHERWISE WOULD BE ADDITIONAL
UTILITIES WOULD BE COUPLE ARE
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT PROGRESSIVE
RETURNS ENSURE EVERYONE IS
CONTRIBUTING ACTIVELY TO THE
COST OF OPERATING THE WATER
SYSTEM. ENSURES THAT THOSE WHO
USED MOST. ALSO PAID THE MOST.
THANK REQUEST YEAR I VOTE ON THE
SUPPORT TO HELP YOU THANK YOU
KNOW WILL TO. JACOBS COLOR.
AMERICAN WATER. THANK YOU CHAIR
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M EVAN JACOBS
DIRECTOR OF EXTERNAL AFFAIRS FOR
CALIFORNIA AMERICAN WATER.
PLEASE ALSO BE TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN SIXTY
NINE. MY UTILITY SERVICE OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS MORE THAN FIFTY
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
. HAVE A RECORD OF DELIVERING
SAFE RELIABLE WATER SERVICE
OFFERING SOME OF THE BEST
CUSTOMER PORTABILITY PROGRAMS
AND CONSERVATION SERVICES
AVAILABLE ANYWHERE. WATER
RESOURCE CHALLENGES FACING OUR
SERVICE AREA ON THE MONTEREY
PENINSULA HIGHLIGHT THE NEED FOR
SB FOURTEEN SIXTY NINE PASSAGE.
COUPLING IS VITAL FOR US TO
BALANCE CONSERVATION ORIENTED
REDESIGNS WITH INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS. WILL HISTORY ON
THE MONTEREY PENINSULA STATE
WATER BOARD- RESTRICTED OUR
ABILITY TO PUMP GROUNDWATER BLOW
THE CARMEL RIVER THANK YOU BYE
SOME OF THE EARLY TWO THOUSANDS
ISSUED A CEASE AND DESIST ORDER
ON THAT PUBLIC. TODAY WE'RE
MEETING THAT ORDER MORE WORK
DOES REMAIN WE HAVE SECURE
SUSTAINABLE SUPPLY THERE TO
PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT AND
SUPPORT DESPERATELY NEEDED
HOUSING AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
THAT'S WHAT. MEDIA ORDER TO DATE
WITH WITH LOOKING STATE TO.
REDUCE CLEARLY TO THE POTABLE
WATER YOU SOME PENINSULA WHOSE
BEEN REDUCED ALMOST 50% THROUGH
PROGRAMS SERVICES INC HERE GREAT
DESIGNS THE TERM STRONG ECONOMIC
PRICE SIGNALS. SAME TIME WILL
SUCCESSFULLY PROVIDED
CONSERVATION MAKE MASSIVE
INVESTMENTS STORMWATER CAPTURE
GROUNDWATER STORAGE IN IN
INDIRECT POTABLE REUSE THANK YOU
FOR ALL MONEY FORMING THE
PENINSULA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR A GREAT WITH MY TIME UP.
HERE TIMES OF. YOUR COMMENTS
VERY MODERATE REGULATED ONE TO
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT HERE IN THE
GALLERY DO WE HAVE ANYBODY WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR
COULD YOU PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN SIXTY
NINE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUREEN SIXTY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN
SIXTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO. LINE FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI NATALIE NEXT ON BEHALF
OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL ACTION FUND AND SUPPORT
. ONE MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER THE
NEXT LINE NUMBER.
ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
ON THE FILE AND I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BORDER EFFICIENCY
PARTNERSHIP WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE THANK
YOU. WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
IN Q. IN SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN
SIXTY NINE. OKAY WE'LL GO TO
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION DO WE
HAVE ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FOURTEEN SIXTY
NINE. I SEE NO ONE- WILL GO TO
THE MODERATOR MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
OF US P. FOURTEEN SIXTY NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FOURTEEN SIXTY NINE. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION SB FOURTEEN SIXTY
NINE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
THERE. WE HAVE NO LINES IN Q. IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. FOURTEEN
SIXTY NINE. OKAY WILL COME TO
THE COMMITTEE NOW FOR MEMBER-
COMMENTS DEBATES QUESTIONS. AND
WE'LL GO TO CENTER BAKER. TWENTY
SEVEN PROUD TO BE A COURSE OF
THIS MEASURE AS AB YOU KNOW KIND
OF LEARN FIRST IN BUSINESS
SCHOOLS ABOUT ALIGNING
INCENTIVES AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL. WOULD DO WE THINK THAT
THE- YOU KNOW THE PC HAS HAS GOT
IT WRONG AND IT'S CRITICAL THAT
YOU SEE REALLY REVISIT THE
ISSUE. AND IT'S A TWO D.
COUPLING- YOU KNOW ULTIMATELY WE
DON'T REALLY WANT TO SPEED
OPTIONAL. FOR THE PROCESS WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE THIS- B. B. JUST
PART OF THE WAY BUSINESS IS DONE
GOING FORWARD SO LOOK FOR
SUPPORTING THE BILL APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR FOR HIS WORK. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND DID YOU
WANNA MAKE A MOTION ON THE BILL.
I'M MOVING ABOUT OKAY WE HAVE A
MOTION TO PASS IS MANAGED
APPROPRIATIONS- CENTER. A
BRADFORD DID YOU WANT TO MAKE.
MAKE A CLOSING COMMENT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THAT'S THE- PERFECT CLOSER
CLOSER- WE HAVE A MOTION CLICK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB
FOURTEEN SIXTY NINE BY SENATOR
BRADFORD THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WESSEL II WESSEL HI DOLLY. BAKER
BAKER HI FORTUS. BRADFORD
BRADFORD HI DODD. EGGMAN
GONZALEZ. GROW HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG I REQUIRE. MAN MAN HI
RUBIO. RUBIO HI STERN STERN HI.
DOT DOT HI. GONZALEZ BY. NINE
ACER OKAY THAT HAS ENOUGH VOTES
TO GET OUT WILL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS WILL
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT BILL S. B.
ITEMEIGHT SB TEN FIFTEEN BY THE
CHAIR HUESO NOW PASSED THE GAVEL
OVER TO CENTER BRADFORD YOU
MAYBE YOU COULD SHARE FROM YOUR
DESK. AND I'LL PRESENT HERE FOR
MINES WE DON'T HAVE TO. INITIATE
CLEANING PROTOCOLS. ALL RIGHT.
WE NEXT JOB UP SB TEN FIFTEEN BY
SENATOR HUESO CENTER HUESO WHEN
YOU'RE PREPARED YOU MAY BEGIN
YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND LIKE TO PRESENT TEN FIFTEEN.
THIS IS AN EFFORT TO ENSURE THAT
OUR BUSIEST COMMERCIAL LAND PORT
OF ENTRY THE OTAY MESA LAND PORT
OF ENTRY. IS NOT OVERLOOKED IN
OUR STATE'S EFFORTS TO ADVANCE
ZERO AND NEAR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE CHARGING. AND I'M
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS PART OF THIS-
PACKAGE. UP. SB TEN FIFTEEN
WOULD DIRECT FUNDING FOR LIGHT
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
TO THE STATE'S BUSIEST
COMMERCIAL LAND PORT OF ENTRY
THE OF ALL TIME EXCELLENT PORT
OF ENTRY- FROM THE CLEAN.
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM FOR
FEDERAL MONIES FOR THIS PURPOSE
WHICHEVER ARE AVAILABLE. IF NOT
BOTH THE- TIME MICHELIN PORT OF
ENTRY HANDLES THE LARGEST VOLUME
OF TRUCK TRAFFIC OVER BOTTOM
BORDER CROSSINGS IN THE STATE
ACCORDING TO THE US DEPARTMENT
OF TRANSPORTATION. BUREAU OF
STATISTICS BASED ON THE MOST
RECENT ANNUAL DATA FOR BORDER
CROSSINGS THE ULTIMATE SUPPORT
VENTURE EXPERIENCE SALUTE
NATION'S THIRD HIGHEST VOLUME OF
TRUCK TRAFFIC. OF ALL THE
NATION'S BORDER CROSSING SECOND
ONLY TO LETTER THOUGH TEXAS AND
DETROIT MICHIGAN. ADDITIONALLY
THERE ARE PLANS UNDERWAY TO
FURTHER EXPAND THE CAPACITY AND
- FACILITY OF ALL TIME IN
SUPPORT OF A TREE WHICH WILL
ALSO EXPAND THE TRUCK VOLUME
ENTRY IN THE SPORT. SO BECAUSE
WE KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF ADDING
UP- CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE TO
OUR ORG STATES CLIMATE GOALS IT
JUST MAKES ONLY SENSE WE WOULD
UP SITE. THIS INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THE AREAS WHERE WE COULD
POTENTIALLY HAVE THE HIGHEST
POLLUTANTS WHERE WE CAN
TRANSITION TO ELECTRIC. VEHICLES
ESPECIALLY IN THE COMMERCIAL
AREA. OF THE STATE HAS
ESTABLISHED SEVERAL STATE
PROGRAMS TO REDUCE GREGORY
POLLUTION GREEN GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS FOR HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES. THESE PROGRAMS INCLUDE
THE TRUCK ABOUT US REGULATION TO
REQUIRE SPECIFIC MINUTE
MITIGATION TECHNOLOGY FOR TRUCKS
AND CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
TO FIND INVESTMENT. IN ZERO ZERO
AND NEAR ZERO EMISSION FLEET
FUELING AND CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR VEHICLES SB
TEN FIFTEEN HELPS TO ENSURE THAT
THE STATE EFFORTS TO FUND ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE CHARGING
TECHNOLOGY. WILL ALSO BE
DIRECTED AT ALL TIME A SALON
FORD OF ENTRY. SO I. WE HAVE
WITH US- SO TESTIMONY PROVIDED
BY THE ATTORNEYS WHO CHAMBER OF
COM MYERS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE HUMDRUM UNITY THAT ON. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR- I
VOTE FOR THIS BILL. YOU WERE
GOING TO MOVE TO OUR WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AND WILL ALLOW YOU
THREE MINUTES TOTAL TO MAKE YOUR
PRESENTATIONS SIR YOU MAY BEGIN
. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
ALEJANDRO. OF YOUR- PROPERTY I
THINK CHAIRMAN WAS INSERTED
PERFECTLY. OUR PORT OF ENTRY
HANDLED MORE THAN THIRTY SEVEN
HUNDRED TRUCKS ON A DAILY BASIS
AN EXPLOSIVE GROWTH IS GOING ON
WITH NEAR SHORING. YOU WANT TO
ENSURE OUR TRUCKS CAN COMPLY
WITH THE NEW MANDATE THE CARD IS
WORKING ON WHICH ARE VERY
IMPORTANT BUT THEY WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO DO SO. IF WE DO NOT HAVE
AN ELECTRIC CHARGING STATIONS.
NEAR THE PORT OF ENTRY OR A PORT
OF ENTRY SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR.
POOR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SIR DO WITNESS
IN SUPPORT. NOBODY NO ONE UP UP
TOP OKAY MODERATOR NOW WILL MOVE
TO THE PHONE LINES WERE LOOKING
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
TEN FIFTEEN. MODERATOR PUSH.
THANK YOU MR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN FIFTEEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
FIFTEEN MAY PRESS ONE AT THE END
ZERO. NINE FORTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ANYTHING THAT WE LACK OF BEHALF
OF THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB
TEN FIFTEEN OKAY WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT NOW WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO OPPOSITION- FOURTH IN
THE SAME OPPORTUNITY ARE THERE
ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION HERE TO TESTIFY ON SB. TEN FIFTEEN. SCENE NO ONE IN
THE GALLERY. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THE PHONE LINES MODERATORS OR
ANYONE IN Q. WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB TEN FIFTEEN
. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB TEN
FIFTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TEN FIFTEEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE
HAVE NO COMMENT IN THE QUEUE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TEN FIFTEEN
OKAY THERE ARE NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THAT ALLOWS US TO
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
IS THERE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ARE REGARDS AS THREE TEN FIFTEEN
. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR DOT
ORG. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
DODD OKAY. NO FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE CENTER HUESO WHICH
LIKE TO CLOSE THIS SIMPLY ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU ARE WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR DODD- THEN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON SB TEN
FIFTEEN. SB TEN FIFTEEN BY
SENATOR WESSEL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO BE AMENDED INTO PART
TRANSPORTATION. WESSEL BY WESSEL
HI DOLLY BAKER. BAKER HI FOR
JUST BRADFORD ARE BRADFORD FIVE
DOT. DODD AYE EGGMAN. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I GROWN HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG HI MCGUIRE MAN MAN HI
RUBIO. RUBIO HI STERN STERN HI.
NINE A SIR. THE BILL IS OUT NINE
VOTES BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN
PERHAPS A MEMBERS. VERY GOOD
THAT BRINGS US TO THE END OF OUR
CALENDAR TODAY- SO WILL LAST
COUPLE YEARS- THAT HAPPENED-
BODHRAN MEASURES PLEASE RETURN
TO THE CHAMBERS AND IN TWO
MINUTES. IN TWO MINUTES WE WILL-
TALLY THE FINAL VOTE.
OKAY WE'RE BACK COMMITTEES BACK
IN- INACTION HERE WE'RE GONNA GO
THROUGH THE BILL'S ONE MORE TIME
AND ALLOW CAPS MEMBERS TO ADD ON
TO THE BILL'S BEGINNING WELL THE
FILE ITEM. NUMBER ONE. S. B.
TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT I CENTER
ALLAN PARK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. SB TWELVE FIFTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR ALAN THE
CURRENT BILL IS NINE ZERO DOLLY
. BAKER READ BAKER HI BRADFORD.
GROWTH MCGUIRE MCGUIRE HI ELEVEN
EASTER. OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE- WILL GO TO
ITEM TWO SB THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE
BY CENTERTON NEWMAN CLERK PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE BY SENATOR
NEWMAN. THE MOTION THAT THE
CURRENT BILL IS EIGHT ONE. DOLLY
BAKER. GONZALEZ GROW. MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE HI IT'S NINE ONE BUT THE
CHAIR. OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT
WILL CLOSE ROLE PEOPLE GO TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. CONSENT
CALENDAR CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO
DOLLY. BAKER BAKER I REQUIRE
REQUIRE HIGH GROWTH. CLOSER TO
THE DOZENS OF THE CONSECUTIVE
YEARS OUT OF CLOSER ROLE NOW
WILL GO TO ITEM NUMBER THREE.
WHICH IS- S. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE BY CENTER CORTESE. BURKE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE BY
SENATOR CORTESE. BROUGH EIGHT
ONE DOLLY BAKER. BAKER FIVE
REGIS. GROSS STERN. MY MENTOR.
THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET
OUT WILL CLOSE TO ROLL ON THAT
BILL NO NUMBER FOUR IS- SB
THIRTY NINETY NINE BY CENTER
WORKOUTS SKI- PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. SB THIRTY NINETY
NINE BY SENATOR MURKOWSKI
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT ZERO. DOLLY
BAKER BAKER HI PORGES. GONZALEZ
GROW STERN. NINE ZERO SURE THAT
HAVE BILL HAS ENOUGH TO GET OUT
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE- NUMBER FOUR
NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE
SB EIGHT EIGHT FOUR BY CENTER
MCGUIRE CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS SB EIGHT FOUR BY
SENATOR REQUIRE CURRENT VOTE
NINE ZERO. DOLLY PORGES RADFORD
. EGGMAN EGGMAN I WROTE. CAN A
STIR OKAY THE BILL HAS ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET OUT OF PHYLLIS
OFFICIALLY OUT WILL CLOSE ROLE
MOVE ONTO A NUMBER- ITEM NUMBER
SIX SB TEN THIRTY TWO BY SENATOR
BAKER BUT PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SB TEN THIRTY TWO BY
SENATOR BAKER CURRENT VOTE SIX
ONE. DOLLY BRADFORD. DODD DOT HI
EGGMAN. EGGMAN I. GROWTH MCGUIRE. REQUIRE HI STERN. THAT NINE
ONE TERM THAT BILL HAS NINE
VOTES IS OFFICIALLY OUT. OF WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE ON THAT BILL WILL
COME TO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN IS P.
FOURTEEN SIXTY NINE BY CENTER
BRADFORD. CLICK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS SB FOURTEEN SIXTY
NINE BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
CURRENT VOTE NINE ZERO DOLLY.
GORGEOUS EGGMAN EGGMAN I GROW
MCGUIRE REQUIRE I. ELEVEN AS
CHAIR THE BILL HAS ELEVEN VOTES
TO OFFICIALLY OUT WILL COME TO
SB TEN FIFTEEN BY CENTER WESSEL
BURKE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SB TEN FIFTEEN BY
SENATOR WESSEL CURRENT VOTE NINE
ZERO. DOLLY GORGEOUS. EGGMAN
EGGMAN HIGH GROWTH REQUIRE
REQUIRE HI. ELEVEN ISTER ELEVEN
VOTES A BILL OUT- WILL CLOSE
ROLE IN THAT ONE. AND I THINK
WE'VE OFFICIALLY. ENDED TODAY'S
BUSINESS I'M NOT MISTAKEN- SO I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED TODAY'S PROCESS.
THANK YOU TO ALL THE SPEAKERS-
AND- THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED PUBLIC TESTIMONY IF
YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE ENERGY
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT
INCLUDE YOU. AND YOUR TESTIMONY
IN THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS
THANK YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU EVERYONE
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WITH CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ENERGY UTILITIES. AND
COMMUNICATIONS IS A JERK.